c'est à toi tu as tu une règle les
cadreurs [ __ ]
non mais c'est vrai j'ai remarqué que tu
aimais bien les cadreurs elle adore les
cadreurs et toi tu aimes les cadreurs
orlando s'il met 4 bien pourquoi ce
cadre bien avec 80 quand même ça arrive
un certain moment qu'elle est gros
plombs il faut les éviter
métier avec le skin contrôle maintenant
on met tous bords avec la technique
aussi gêné à londres de plus venant de
moi ça va c'est que c'est la 200e là je
suis content que tu sois là
[Applaudissements]
c'est la guerre centièmes c'est à dire
qu'elle à l'émission c'est un triomphe
ouais faut dire aussi que cette émission
est devenu le rendez vous incontournable
du samedi soir même au magazine crazy
vas-y vas-y demandé qu'on lui mourir
[Applaudissements]
c'était merveille dans cette émission je
pense que c'est la seule que tu donne le
pouvoir aux gens de répondre expliqué il
ya un dialogue
il ya un dialogue
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais sérieux est ce que tu trouves que
j'existe bien clé parce que c'est ce que
je le fais suffisamment souvent est ce
que tu es content moi ça dépend des fois
tu es bien des fois tu la vois moins de
timbres et ouais là des fois
voilà je pense qu'il faudrait un peu de
trafic le sont orlando exige le cuit
d'ailleurs ce sujet doit dire quelque
chose serait extraordinaire comme aime
le pouvoir de la télévision est ce que
tu en as fait de cette phrase là oui
parce que moi avons quand je rencontre
les gens me disaient ah merci pour ce
que tu fais pour dalida ou d'autres
graves au pour hélène ségara est là
depuis quelques temps d'ailleurs c'est
comme ça commence à devenir un danger
pour moi parce qu'on va oublier tout ce
que j'ai fait alors me dis alors on
exige le clipper round au web et aux
serge et tu sais que ça dépassait les
frontières parce que c'est pas
simplement à paris ou en français
j'étais au maroc pareil à l'aéroport on
exige des clips à rome gta semaine
dernière à rome alors à l'aéroport
d'ailleurs si tu m'appelles au téléphone
ouais ton que j'étais obligé sur mon
répondeur exige qu'on laisse un message
message
dis moi tu sais qu'à partir de janvier
c'est plus orlando exige le clip c'est
orlando exige le slip ça dépend quelle
marque c
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
ami de l'homme en noir
bienvenue sur le plateau de tout le
monde en parle émission qui parle avec
nous ce soir
brad pitt
[Applaudissements]
home sharing groupe
les verts
angelina jolie
john oliver stone
judith godrèche
[Musique]
arsène
[Applaudissements]
oh
andré dussollier joseph macé scaron
les grosses machines
fs de là je sens ciel avec michèle
bernier et
[Musique]
g
pascal sellem
donc sur le plateau de la 200e de tout
le monde en bas mais ce plateau on va le
quitter immédiatement on se retrouve
lundi matin c'était au bristol magnéto
serge magie de la télévision se retrouve
dans un salon de l'hôtel bristol laurent
ça ne change pas beaucoup ça ne change
pas beaucoup axé ma cantine depuis 25
ans j'accueille brad pitt
j'arrive à prendre
[Musique]
damon
est dingue schiller
[Musique]
west georgia je ne sens pas très bien il
voulait venir mais l'étau californie il
est en train de soigner son dos il ya
des médecins qui s'occupent de lui mais
il ira bien d'ici une semaine on espère
un baril avait peur de rencontrer céline
balitran vous pensez n'ont montré qu'il
faut alors bonsoir à tous merci de
sortir votre film
la semaine de la 200e de tout le monde
en parle c'est très cool ça nous fait
une bonne promo c'est vraiment gentil je
crois qu'ils l'ont fait exprès si vous
pouviez sortir le prochain pour la 300e
ça serait vraiment très très cool merci
beaucoup
vous restez quand même temps à paris une
journée en reste encore un jour vous
êtes arrivé carrière toujours d'ailleurs
il ya deux jours j'ai fait piquer
benjamin dans un resto génie à dire soit
vous savez la ville où l'ami louis ah
bah oui si vous avez prévu quelque chose
ce soir l'avant-première
on va voir au sun store italien c'est
une proposition on pouvait voir des
progrès mais comme ça
quand j'en ai déjà fait hier soir est ce
que vous avez prévu un rendez vous avec
nicolas sarkozy
non non parce que tom cruise quand il
est venu à paris la dernière fois il
était allé voir nicolas sarkozy pour
défendre sa secte de scientologie
nous on a des bracelets rouge entrée
dans la can nous a tous vu un cadavre
c'est quelque chose qui ne m'a donné il
adore les fans de madonna
vous savez que vous pouvez rester à
paris tant que george bush est président
des états unis si vous voulez on peut
vous offrir l'asile politique
[Rires]
si one to stay alors vous allez passer
une journée ici dans cet hôtel à
répondre aux mêmes questions des
journalistes français est-ce que c'est
pas fatiguant finalement c'est place
jack est en fait tout ce qu'on fait ici
à la façon dont on travaille ici tous
ensemble en fait on s'amuse bien aux
smart ouais c'est vrai que finalement le
temps passe vraiment vite
c'est la première est la première
personne à personne
c'est un sport dont ces questions sont
un petit peu plus original ça va alors
ça me rassure en tous les cas
pendant l'interview si vous voulez faire
un petit break si vous voulez vous
dégourdir les jambes
boire un verre
vous
[Musique]
qui coiffe et alors vous êtes ici pour
la sortie de chaîne ce qu elle veut
produit par jerry weintraub réalisé par
steven soderbergh avec brad pitt matt
damon donne fidèles qui sont ici
présents plus du lias roberts catherine
zeta-jones george clooney
andy garcia vincent cassel qui sont
absents voilà alors tout le monde
connaît l'historique de cette série
d'abord en 1960 un film de lewis
milestone intitulé au channel vannes en
amérique et l'inconnu de las vegas en
france qui réunit frank sinatra et son
rap pâques à dean martin sammy davis
peter l'eau fort quarante ans plus tard
un remake ocean's eleven produit par
jerry weintraub réalisé déjà par steven
soderbergh avec cette idée du méga
casting le film fait un carton et c'est
à rome pendant la tournée promotionnelle
de ocean's eleven que l'équipe est
interrogé pour la première fois sur
l'éventualité d'une suite à donner à
ocean's eleven alors jerry soderbergh
avait envie de tourner à rome
et c'est ce qui a amené l'idée de faire
une une suite
en europe on était allé dîner un rom
avec steven après la conférence de
presse à rome et steven
a eu une idée une idée pour le film qui
on en a parlé ce soir là dans l'avion et
je crois que ça devait être à peu près à
mi-chemin
il avait déjà écrit il a produit le
premier acteur mais bon on a attendu
trois ans parce qu'il y a travaillé
pendant trois ans et puis ensuite il a
eu une idée précise et voilà mais voilà
c'est un petit peu sont le fruit de son
imagination alors de retour à los
angeles jerry vous trouvez un scénario
qui met aux prises le plus grand voleur
américain et son rival européen vous
envoyé le script à jaws cluny à brad
pitt à soderbergh qu'il aime il apprécié
l'histoire
ils ont apprécié l'histoire
après cela il veut travailler sur le
scénario avec thurgovie donc de cette
liste en effet ils ont manière à ce que
ça puisse fonctionner quand vous avez
reçu le scénario brad tout de suite vous
avez eu envie de faire le film
immédiatement pas vraiment mais enfin
j'ai ri a menacé de mettre édition des
tribus locales donc sur le plan
contractuel n'était pas échappé à cette
corvée et j'avais sept ont pris pour la
suite
est ce que c'est vrai que tu te brad
pitt là vous demandé aux scénaristes de
diviser l'escroc américain par pas rose
puisque départ c'était 2-2 voleurs
simplement oui pour que pour que ça
fonctionne pour nous jeunes amants du
café c'est toujours ça brade quand même
du café méo
amy le dra 10 ans est tombé non c'est
tombé sexe du sexe sexe sexe c'est paris
on est à paris évidemment oui alors le
pitch dossier heinze twelve ces trois
ans après le fameux braquage donc des
trois plus prestigieux casino de las
vegas
andy garcia retrouve la piste des
voleurs et les oblige à se rendre en
europe pour y commettre des braquages
destinée à le rembourser voilà voilà
l'histoire
alors pour récupérer la somme andy
garcia fait appel à vincent cassel qui
est un grand escroc international et qui
apparaît pour la première fois donc dans
dans la série pourquoi vincent cassel
ouailles
[Rires]
vincent cassel et est aujourd'hui un
sort à cannes quand steven soderbergh
est aussi très important dans laquelle
était impliqué low-kick étaient des
informations très important le rôle
allemonière cinq ans jerry a été
acquitté pourquoi m'en suis né je me
contiens il était inquiet
à rennes la pression et
il a dit qu'il aimait beaucoup les
filles qu'avec vincent est trouvé qu'ils
avaient un rôle qui allait vraiment bien
marché pour vincent il a été ravi tendue
proposée est d'ailleurs il a fait sa
remarquable est tous passés par là tous
les acteurs quelqu'un l'a d'or depuis le
début de sa quête
il est probable meilleur acteur que nous
voyons en outre il faut quelqu'un qui
est sur le poids et il était vraiment il
faisait tout à fait la fête ce qui est
drôle c'est que d'enchaîner les vannes
la bande arriver à surmonter tous les
obstacles et dans nos chaînes twelve sa
foire dès le début c'est un scénario
très original parce que ça commence très
mal en fait
c'est vrai que c'est un film qui peut
qu'on peut regarder c'est pas forcément
la suite d'un autre film on est vraiment
très fier de ça il aura sa propre
carrière ce film en faire un film qui
soit nouveau nous offrait exaltant
personne n'a envie de voir la suite d'un
film qui a déjà été fait donc vraiment
ça a bien marché mais ça déjà beaucoup
de succès c'est très bien mais bien une
idée géniale c'est l'utilisation de
julia roberts
je vais pas le dire parce que si les
gens vont voir le film il faut pas leur
dire ce qui se passe mais je vous
félicite et tout le monde qui verra le
film appréciera ce qui a eu cette idée
d'utiliser giulia roberts comme ça
c'était l'idée de steven je crois c'est
estimer at on expliqué
non c'est vrai que c'est la chose la
plus drôle que j'ai pu chez julien
revert c'est vraiment vraiment au top
c'est extraordinaire c'est une très
bonne idée on veut simplement dire aussi
la cdb tout récemment et c'était pas lui
rien avant que ce soit un cas là dessus
a échappé à ces trois ans la hausse est
de préciser maintenant ça va être à sa
lettre à vous de faire un bébé parce que
maintenant jennifer aniston haletant
l'arrêté frappe un piège et tu te
tombent dedans alors on va voir à quoi
ça ressemble vous allez regarder votre
caméra celcal rouge et vous allez dire
tous les quatre en même temps magnéto
serge caméra serge many to black light
magnétophone magnéto certes l'accès des
magnétos c'est quoi on est vraiment des
saints janvier
vers la grimace et lamballe enseignants
et maintenant vous partez
ouais je veux qu'on me rende mon fric le
fric vous avez volé 160 millions de
dollars avec les intérêts je ne sais pas
seulement on a cherché les annonceurs
enfin il nous faut un job un job qui
fait le maximum pour l'instant on est
grillé on peut plus travailler dans ce
pays pourri ce combat
[Musique]
tu pars en repérage le jour de notre
anniversaire tess et vous êtes monsieur
miguel diaz vous vous appelez greg
grecque
j'aimerais un renseignement vous avez
des coffres pour les particuliers c'est
pas dans ma nature d'être mystérieux
mais jenny droit d'en parler ni droit de
dire pourquoi
oh
bien que cette fois on confie un rôle un
peu plus central gerard problème pas ce
qui s'est passé là dedans qu'est ce que
j'ai dit
prochaine rencontre je vous arrête à
tous ça veut dire qu'il est plus frais
bien toi je veux tout mon fric bien
parce que j'ai un réseau d'amis dans ma
voiture
merci commence à voir sa peine
je me sens très bien pour un homme mort
ok
mais tu m'as dit qu il nous appelait les
bans de shon kylie a décidé de ça oui je
sais que tu vas devoir jouer un petit
rôle dans cette histoire un petit rôle
je suis censée être au quai monsieur yao
chen qui est le plus grand voleur monde
êtes vous sûr d'être meilleur que moi
d
voilà ocean toile de steven soderbergh
un film excellent que je vous conseille
d'aller voir il ya cette idée du lait
roberts que je vous conseille
d'apprécier voilà alors jerry réunir une
telle brochette de stars
une fois c'est déjà très difficile mais
deux fois et en rajoutant catherine
zeta-jones et vincent cassel sont encore
plus fort pour maintenant comment vous
fait quel est votre secret jerry
weintraub énormément chance tout ce
qu'il faut faire sa place et un guide
qui les avait tous vraiment envie de se
retrouver ils sont tous à mi temps à
l'écran qu'à la ville il avait envie de
travailler avec soderbergh et voilà
c'est vraiment facile n'a pas difficile
du tout nous c'est pas aussi difficile
qu'on a donnée le vendu son âme au
diable
tout est possible en tous les cas il
semble que les acteurs se soient bien
amusés ensemble est-ce que vous nous
racontez brad cette note de service que
vous avez dicter au sujet de george
clooney et ensuite il s'est vengé wa10
tôt eagle heureuse voilà l'histoire dit
que quelqu'un avait transmis une note à
l'équipe italienne
disons qu'elle venait de jazz in et qui
demandait à l'équipe de saint louis en
l'appelant monsieur daniel sociaux
pendant tout le tournage sur l'écran et
ailleurs et merci de coopération que
pour que le personnage qui se
retrouvaient mais plutôt que pour que
l'acheteur puisse trouver le personnage
qu'on tourne alors quelqu'un aurait
diffusé donc cette note la vérité c'est
georges et il se prend d'amour pour la
nar on l'a perdue ça veut dire que tu
changes
il était vraiment il était parti il se
prenait pour dany au site
non mais ce qui s'est passé qui est
incroyable c'est donc brad fait pas ses
notes en disant clown et il faut
l'appeler motion parce que sinon il se
vexe qu'il faut vraiment être très
différent avec lui et ensuite de retour
à los angeles
george clooney s'est vengé de brad pitt
en mettant un autocollant sur votre
voiture à y en avait deux d'autocollants
le premier c'était je suis gay et je
vote
mais le deuxième c'était which le
deuxième c'était petit pénis à bord
small pénis en bois
je n'ai pas compris la blague d'ailleurs
je voyais pas une fan s'était
particulièrement drôle alors lequel sur
le tournage lequel a fait le plus de
conneries de faire c'est de se
concentrer sur le fait qu'il faut l'idée
georges parce que en fait il est tombé
de la falaise il est tombé dans le
goutte d'eau tension le fait qu'ils
s'approprient personnage de danny et
donc on lui on lui lance une bouée de
sauvetage voici leur atténuation serait
bien quand il disait ça dit puis mes
yeux j'aime profondément dans l'océan
des pignons je dirais que ça et il croit
vraiment qu'il est le mari de julia
roberts
bien sûr la pap la pelleteuse c'est bien
il ya toute une équipe de psychologues
qui sont en train de s'occuper de lui
maintenant 24 heures sur 24 mais donc ça
ira ça pose problème sur le tournage qui
avait le plus grand car loges
[Applaudissements]
c'est comme ça que ça doit être
lequel a été le plus payé sur le
tournage lequel est lequel a été le plus
radin il faut choisir quelqu'un c'est
vrai qu'il vous a c'est moi qui vous a
fait payer la location de sa villa au
lac de côme non superbe depuis deux
semaines plus tard soit la ville on l'a
pas payé un peu mal poli je trouve alors
quand vous étiez en europe lequel avait
le plus de succès dans la rue f cfa
lequel a trompé sa femme pendant le
tournage mais c'est quoi en mai en
france aux états unis sucer c'est
tromper
ah oui lécher le pénis de sa femme
ses parents technique si on lit la bible
c'est pas dans la bible
c'est donc cette patron c'est bon les
différences de culture entre un
continent et un autre en france s'est
pas trompé non et chez vous s'est trompé
pourquoi vous visez pas en france
non non non c'est pas qu'on peut penser
qu'il ya pas photo
lequel s'est fait draguer par des mecs
pendant le tournage il les a laissés
faire
lequel n'avait pas lu le scénario avant
le tournage lequel est d'accord pour
faire autre chose
fatin pense que tout le monde sera
d'accord pour le faire rejouer cette île
forte c'est la décision reviendra une
somme que s'ils veulent faire ben oui
tout le monde reviendra c'est sûr
d'accord s'il veut pas le film se fera
pas dire que la validation pour nom et
ce serait aux jeunes ce 30 centimes et
george clooney en superstar non mais ça
n'a pas été fait encore vous devez
dépenser donne becoming france
là pendant l'émission pas je me sens je
le sens bien ici je me sens bien
lequel va aller aux toilettes maintenant
bon parce qu'on aime
titouan de jeu bordelais que les stars
se font pas kaka 6 6 606 ils auront
comme nous
[Musique]
y aller
by ap les ché
fario
[Musique]
comme soirée
m
pas bien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'accord maquillage
[Musique]
en même temps
hélas
la culture prend les choses en main sa
note encore ok je viens d'inde donc brad
mater donne vous est ce qu'on appelle
des stars d'hollywood
est ce que le fait d'être une star
d'hollywood ça aide
avec les filles et fils des deux sexes
et un aphrodisiaque ça rapporte ça
rapporte beaucoup de monnaie d'argent
sur moi oui je crois que j'ai encore le
chocolat ils sont un peu d'argent ah oui
tu es très riche regarde pas il faut
faire quoi comme études pour être star
d'hollywood finance finance les bonnes
réponses quand on est une star
d'hollywood est ce que c'est vrai qu'on
peut exiger un jet privé pour rentrer
dîner le soir à la maison lui demander
de rentrer sur coup lors on peut refuser
d'assister aux cérémonies des oscars
parce qu'on a un truc mieux à faire ce
jour là
c'est pour ça qu'il est si sérieux
problèmes
non ceci étant on peut être une star
d'hollywood et malgré tout on en est pas
moins homme est ce que quand on est une
star d'hollywood
il arrive que quand on est sur la plage
on rentre le ventre je vois de rythme
johnny qui donne évidemment mais aussi
sur la plage enfin l'interdiction a été
levée donc c'est jerry je vous demande
pas à vous si vous rentrez le ventre
quand vous allez sur la plage parce que
vous n'avez pas de ventre non c'était
des producteurs y z'ont ce gaz est
leader et cigare c'est vrai est-ce que
vous commencez à perdre vos cheveux non
non non non non est ce que le matin
quand vous vous réveillez des fois vous
avez vraiment une haleine de poney comme
nous vous faites vos courses le week-end
non vous étonner c'est vraiment bizarre
c'est le paradoxe c'est bien parce que
une fois que vous êtes arrivé à un point
où vous permet de vous acheter tout ce
que vous voulez a finalement tout est
gratuit
est-ce que des fois quand même vous
regarder le foot à la télé en buvant de
la bière comme no est ce qu'il vous
arrive de pisser dans le lavabo
alors brad vous avez été élu plusieurs
fois l'homme le plus sexy du monde
waouh c'est vrai que c'est assez
difficile de porter sa couronne
enfin georges aussi savait il qu'il a
été élu lors comment une note sexy à
c'est le même problème alors en fait je
puisse puisque l'académie a été sympa
avec nous on essaie de le lui rendre a
ouvert une école pour les nouveau
sex-symbol ma cela fait une très bonne
campagne mais lui en s'appliquant un peu
jerry massie donne un peu de mal
il en va le prix cette année matt signal
est fort quand on est l'homme le plus
sexy de la planète on est aussi l'homme
le plus harcelés de la planète comment
vous vivez ça brade en corse et du ski
il faut se balader incognito avec avec
des déguisements
il faut pas être repris dans une
situation compromettante parce que sinon
évidemment la personne perd son titre
c'est difficile mais si jamais ça
arrivait par exemple on verra ce que
commande ou de son temps cette année à
5,6 joutes tomber tu m as tu as une
chance
moi je me vois comme un deuxième coup
toi remplaçants potentiels donc qu'à ses
entraînements il perd son titre - il n'y
a pas de problème je peux prendre le
large
c'est vrai que vous lisez jamais les
tabloïds vous lisez pas les articles qui
vous concernent dans cette presse là
c'est ainsi que la presse à scandales
donc
gk d'argent d'ailleurs en faisant ça
avec plein de gens que moi qu'on s'est
bien marré ouais non non vous savez pas
en fait que maintenant que vous savez
pas que maintenant que jennifer aniston
a fini france vous avez à vous allez
avoir le temps d'être papa maintenant
vous savez j'avais c'était ça gèle pas i
want ou bien tu as dit alors match match
vous avez vous avez cessé de fumer en
seulement trois séances d'hypnose
après 16 ans de cigarettes est ce que
vous allez arriver à persuader brad pitt
de le faire à son tour cilic a tenu le
nom de la personne qui m'a guéri donc
alors vous avez déclaré en parlant de
brad pitt si j'étais homosexuel il
serait en poster dans ma chambre j'ai
vraiment amoureux de lecture d'erreur
vous avez pas peur matt que cela rentre
jaloux votre votre ami ben affleck nom
fait référence au fait qu'on parlait de
lui et moi qui étais au lycée c'était
pendant une interview nous a dit écoute
regarde si on était vraiment gay dans
tous les deux mois une photo prise avec
toi et puis ensuite on se déplace à
prendre toutes les photos de bras sur ce
mur allie donc moi je n'ai pas parlé
récemment et je sais pas vous avez
déclaré quand même en parlant de ben
affleck que finalement de vos goûts vos
histoires d'amour dure et jamais plus
longtemps que deux ans et demi et que
vous verriez bien finir votre vie en
compagnie de ben affleck c'est vrai ça
où c'était juste parce que le magazine
c'était advocate
j'ai dit ça
je ne dis rien je veux vraiment pas le
vieillir avec nie toujours me donne vous
avez déclaré je me sens frustré parce
que la plupart des écrivains blanc ne
font pas leurs recherches sur
l'expérience noire
les scénaristes écrivent pour des
acteurs qui rapporte afrique et les
acteurs qui rapporte du fric ce sont
souvent des blancs bien entendu le
soufre est nécessaire
ouais c noyer survie commence à
vintimille et déjà ça mais c'est vrai
que je souffre mais
mais pas
montrer comment accomplir ce rituel à
satan et je crois que ça m'a vraiment
beaucoup pdl
alors en france il ya un problème il ya
pas beaucoup d'acteurs noirs dans les
fip est ce que vous auriez un conseil à
leur donner pour prendre la place qui
leur revient dans la société française
oui c'est vrai qu'en france il avait une
tradition de révolte des musées je crois
que si les noirs se mettaient en soirée
a été prise et toute l'industrie se
serait parti non mais enfin je
plaisantais sérieusement je dirais
continuer persévérer et persévérer
n'acceptait pas qu'on vous refuser quoi
que ce soit merci à john wayne avec brad
pitt avec georges tommy john et robert
autres matt damon
une cigale et vincent cassel réalisé par
soderbergh est produit par jerry
weintraub voilà merci merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
l'entente
dans les salons de l'hôtel bristol avec
brad pitt matt damon greenshield et
diane 23
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'accueille maintenant il avait lu père
[Musique]
bonsoir isabelle et peur à mes lui fait
pas peur
ça va là vous êtes bien oui ça va en
tous les cas vous êtes extrêmement rare
dans les talk shows je vous remercie
d'être là pour la 200e de tout le monde
en parle ça nous fait plaisir parce qu
on vous admire beaucoup alors on
commence comme et on se lance alors vous
êtes ici pour un film qui sort mercredi
qui s'appelle les soeurs fâchées
d'alexandra leclère avec vous catherine
frot françois berléand brigitte catillon
michel viard moss voilà alors j'ai
beaucoup aimé un mois je vais vous dire
franchement on dit à isabelle huppert
qui vient dans l'émission il faut que tu
ailles voir son film lundi après midi au
club presse bon j'y vais un tu en voilà
et quand j'arrive là-bas je sais pas du
tout ce que je vais voir je m'assois
tout seul dans cette salle très
confortable faut bien le dire
et là franchement j'ai été cueillis j'ai
été cueillis ça m'a beaucoup plu
ça m'a même un peu bouleversé je dois
dire donc voilà je voulais vous le dire
alors le pitch c'est facile c'est le
titre les soeurs fâchées
voilà donc c'est le pitch alors il ya
vous vous êtes là soeurs parisiennes
riche bien habillé vous un bel
appartement mais vous êtes quand même
très très froid très très blasé un peu
agressive 1 un peu oui en fait vous êtes
mal
on sent bien que vous êtes mal dans
votre peau je veux dire nous ennuie ya
peu dans cette vous est un petit jeu
c'est surtout l'arrivée de delà de ma
soeur qui est jouée par catherine frot
qui a une grande capacité à
l'émerveillement où est arrivée la bona
voilà c'est à dire elle c'est le
provincial extraverti chaleureuse
enthousiaste elle s'émerveille de tout
mais elle devient gentil quand même
envahissante quoi c'est un révélateur
mais c'est aussi un peu un ange
exterminateur son irruption dans la vie
de sa soeur va renvoyer sa soeur au vide
de sa vie ou ratage de son mariage à
l'échec de ses amitiés de sa vie voilà
bah oui effectivement on peu à peu on
découvre que votre agressivité en fait
ça cache une grande fragilité est
quelque chose de cassé dans le
personnage que vous incarnez et et en ce
qui concerne catherine frot on voit
qu'elle devient vraiment pénible au bout
d'un moment quoi tu y as espèce de
gentillesse comme ça sans arrêt ça
devient ce bien fatiguant et les rôles
s'inversent d'une certaine façon dont
c'est ça qui est intéressant dans le
film oui il ya une espèce de double
mouvement est encore en particulier pour
mon personnage qui consiste à ce que
plus elle est vulnérable et plus elle
est agressive
ouais alors belle histoire c'est cette
soeur catherine frot qui esthéticienne
en province qui avec une grande histoire
d'amour à la quitter son jules et elle
est tellement contentes de son nouveau
jules celle s'élever pendant un an à 6
heures ou 7 heures du matin pour écrire
un bouquin qu'elle a envoyée aux
éditions grasset et grasse et lui a
donné rendez vous est donc elle vient
pour signer son contrat alors bon vous
vous êtes quand même vous faire moitié
plaisir quand même de voir ça ça ne peut
pas tellement plaisir surtout que moi je
suis une femme oisive kir et kiki kirin
qui réalise surtout à la faveur de de
cet événement que je suis totalement
dépendante de son mari et que je sais
qu'au fond j'aimerais bien travailler
aussi
voilà et quand vous essayer de
travailler vous rendez compte que
personne ne vous propose rien quoi
oui ça c'est un peu dérisoire a les
traits de travailler dans la galerie de
peinture de son ami le temps son ami
veut pas vu confier la galerie de
peinture quand même fait alors j'ai
regardé votre caméra c'est le diable
rouge voilà éviter bien magnétosphère
voilà c'est fait à ces faits bah oui je
les dis
payez pas madame vous pouvez aller
chercher votre soeur à la gare à j'avais
complètement oublié ça fait plaisir
d'être à paris j'avais oublié comme
c'était bouché toi ô grand et ça discute
en france c'est épuisant n'y a rien qui
te faire coucou
qu'est ce que tu fais là la soeur de
martin et oui tu as vu ce qu'est ce que
c'est beau ça fait au moins deux mois
que j'ai réservé les places qu'ils
étaient un peu tu trouves pas que là on
voit connaisseurs c'est quelque chose me
tape sur les nerfs à ça j'adore ça je
peux pas résister j p
tu repars quand je suis là ce soir je
peux repartir lundi soir steve mais non
c'était juste pour savoir je disais pas
ça pour ça
et non pas ce qu'est ce qu'il est bon
c'est pas du mousseux en a tellement
qualité vous allez d'autres sont à
l'aise parce qu'il ya deux minutes tu
disais que tu avais du mal à parler mais
là je vois que ça va mieux mais bon tu
veux tu peux pas faire attention
une femme jalouse qui ne laisse rien
passer la personne regarde ta tête
tête de jalousie
j'en peux plus d'aller de sa fausse
modestie je suis de trop les soeurs
fâchées d'alexandra leclère avec
catherine frot
ils avaient mon père qui m'a invité ce
soir alors moi je me suis un peu reconnu
quand même dans le personnage que vous
incarnez puisque c'est vrai que des
poèmes et de la famille ou des amis qui
viennent de province je me rends compte
à quel point les plus en quoi
mais moi je crois qu'en fait c'est un
peu le même personnage qu'est laquelle a
qu'elle a distribué donnée dans les deux
personnages il ya une vraie profondeur
dans le film qui consiste parce que ce
personnage qui a été fermée aux autres
pendant tout le film finalement à la
toute fin du film il ya un mouvement
vers l'autre il ya un mouvement vert
vers sa soeur c'est une fin assez
ouverte et optimiste voilà alors c'est
un premier film
oui vous êtes bon faire des trucs comme
ça quand même surtout elle qui vont
filer en l'occurrence un faut beaucoup
de courage et beaucoup de volonté pour
faire pour faire un premier film et et
elle en a vu oui et c'est vrai qu'un
premier film c'est toujours un petit
saut dans l'inconnu mais il y avait
quelque chose dans le scénario il y
avait il y avait il y avait des très
très bon dialogue surtout il y avait des
comme la première réplique du film par
exemple elle dit à son mari
je pense que je vais le dire parce que
ceux ci soient sur lui a dit tu peux
arrêter de respirer s'il te plaît c'est
vrai que respirent tout le temps c'était
une manière assez quand même joyeuse de
flers bascule lorsque pedro le cycle et
réalisatrice alexandra leclère elle vous
a abordé devant l'école de vote ni fils
et elle vous a dit je les écris pour
vous donc quand quelqu'un vous dit j'ai
écrit un scénar pour vous ça doit être
très difficile de de refuser quand même
on sent un peu embringué dans la sphère
non oui c'est à dire ça évidemment ça
retient l'attention mais comme elle m'a
abordé d'une manière assez particulière
dans dans la rue j'avais pas de
suspicion enfin je ne me suis pas non
plus précipitée pour le lire j'ai
attendu un petit peu qu'il y avait des
matins je changeais trottoir je disais
ce budget toujours pas du scénario enfin
vous êtes sûr de rencontrer un bâtiment
mais finalement j'étais obligé de le
lire oui c'est à nous de saison et puis
finalement j'ai
et là je me suis dit a fait le lien oui
ça se passe comment avec vos soeurs ça
se passe bien et pas de problème et donc
c'est pas toi même fâché vous vous êtes
quand même assez souvent fait cher il se
trouvait moche mais non pas ce soir je
vois là je trouve génial là ce soir
souriante et ou non je suis pas je suis
pas fâché je suis aux aguets
oui voilà on peut pas dire que vous
soyez dans l'empathie constante comme
comme d'autres gens quoi vous n'êtes pas
même un petit peu sur votre quant-à-soi
quoi c'est à dire que quand on fait
quelque chose de qu'on aime finalement
la moindre des choses peut-être c'est
oui c'est de développer une certaine
violence finalement vis-à-vis de ce
qu'on fait pour que ça soit mieux
possible
voilà c'est pas forcément une preuve de
d'amitié que d'être toujours d'accord
avec ce qui vous arrive non quelquefois
il faut choisissez souvent des
personnages qui sont peu aimable voire
négatif ça oui j'aime bien moi vous
plaisir mais ça me plaît de pas plaire
oui ça ça me plaît beaucoup et ça c'est
bien j'aime pas trop les gens qui font
tout pour plaire oui voilà
il leur faisait beaucoup de mal à parler
de vous mais qu'est-ce que je fais là
puis un quart d'heure dont vous parlez
de votre fils madiabel oui mais en face
c'est une manière dj ron de parler de
moi le très pudique où est d'ailleurs
voyez je suis déjà tout rouge parce
qu'elle se dit voilà ce qu'il en a fini
les jours on a fini la promo donc il a
imposé des desseins personnels dans
mecelec louis dit john de parler de moi
vite il faut du courage pour parler de
soi oui mais je dis aussi que on a le
droit à l'introspection qu'on a droit
on a le droit de ne pas ne pas tout dire
d'ailleurs ça se comprend pas ce que
vivent en dehors de mes films j'ai envie
d'être rien jour il n est plus là oui là
qu'en fait vous vous existez en fait
quand vous tournez quoi c'est pour ça
que c'est une grande comédienne
oui je ne sais pas m'en passer quand
même là que je sais que j'existe le way
pas le mieux parce que j'existe aussi
j'espère en dehors de mes films et en
tous les cas heureux quand même parce
que vous avez peur à une famille
mais vous aussi wii boxing moi j'en
parle volontiers la différence oui non
mais vous dis je suis devenue actrice
par goût du silence car plus vous
employer les mots des autres
- vous êtes apte à livrer ceux qui sont
au fond de vous c'est pas très original
je sais que c'est moins cher des jours à
l'annoncé très très bien au contraire
dire qu'en fait vous vous cherchez des
gens qui vous écrive des dialogues où
vous faites des pièces de théâtre n'est
ce pas obligé de parler vous quand même
c'est à dire oui enfin un écran
c'est l'écran du cinéma au graff s'est
fait pour montrer pour pour cacher année
commence à cash
oui donc voila vous casser mais je je je
je profite de ce que l'écran me permet
de faire à la fois de montrer de me
cacher je m'en prive pas avait des
circonstances atténuantes parce que
votre père dirigeait une entreprise qui
fabriquait des coffres forts
donc c'est vrai dans le genre ça permet
à la confidence voilà sa plus jeune
enfance à ville d'avray 1b dit dans ces
noms c'est tout c'est tout on n'ira pas
plus loin l'enfance à ville d'avray
il ya un très beau film les dimanches du
mois d'avril a été génial avec un acteur
allemand a redit kruger hardy kruger
bravo un film de serge bourguignon on
serait à monsieur cinéma vous avez
maintenant voilà j'aurais gagné
des prêts pour gardillou là non vous
pensez à quoi là à rien a tant mieux
ouais ça m'arrive souvent c'est bien
pour ça que c'est une grande comédienne
nous arriver complètement à faire le
vide et vous remplir des personnages non
mais sérieux c'est pas toi ici la nation
quand vous regardez le matin dans la
glace vous dites quoi rien vous auriez
me ressemble et agit comme vous étiez
petit
un personne c'est vrai c'est vrai ah oui
vraiment vous avez pleuré quand pour la
dernière fois mais cela j'étais en
larmes dans ma loge mais vous savez
comment arrivez vous changeriez quoi en
vous si vous aviez une baguette magique
rien qu'est ce que vous pourriez dire de
plus négatif sur vous rien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
si votre vie était à refaire qu'est-ce
que vous changeriez rien mais vous
devriez appelez votre interne ou l'art
dit rien alors rien vraiment vraiment
dans sérieux on va et sérieux vraiment
sérieux qui avez vous le plus envie
d'épater personnes non mes joueuses non
c'est vrai vos enfants votre mari non
hier sept bandits qui vous dit ce moment
tu es génial ou ma chérie tu
extraordinaire non non ne me dise pas
souvent ah ouais que feriez vous si vous
restez 24 heures à vivre à part rien
qu'est ce que je ferais rien vous êtes
déjà pensé au suicide
[Musique]
non non non non vous me demandez ça
parce que c'est parce que c'est la
review ouais c'est lardy view il est
comme ça pour tout le monde
de quelle question aimeriez vous avoir
la réponse celle que vous venez de me
poser
[Musique]
qu'est ce que la vie nous a appris rien
j'espère rien encore comment auriez-vous
mourir mais j'aimerais mieux pas ouais
vous avez menti pendant cette interview
là tout le temps
[Musique]
alors du 13 janvier au 5 mars
vous êtes et dagobert d'après ipsen sur
la scène du théâtre de l'odéon mise en
scène d'eric lacascade vous est parfaite
pour faire des vagues à blair ait on
annule 2,3 récemment été moins bien
trouvé que vous quand même
j'étais pas du jamais vu et d'accabler
pas bon non c'est vrai j'ai jamais vu
représentés mais ça va pas ça va pas
vous mettre de bonne humeur où la pièce
est quand même très très dur un oui mais
c'est vraiment une pièce extraordinaire
et puis c'est une pièce très mystérieuse
hedda gabler il ya beaucoup de gens qui
disent qu'ils ont jamais rien compris à
dacca blair mais en fait je pense que je
sais pas j'ai l'impression que depuis
qu'elle a été écrite
c'est le genre de d'héroïne ne serait ce
que par exemple dans les films de
chabrol made me fait beaucoup penser à
une héroïne chabrolienne dont la
complexité ne fait moins peur et je
crois qu'il ya plus de clés maintenant
pour pour accepter de pas comprendre ce
genre de comportement et puis c'est une
écriture vraiment extraordinaire où là
où justement les mots ne sont pas
réducteur dans la mesure où ils ne sont
pas essentiels ce qui est essentiel
c'est qu'il ya c'est ce qu'il ya entre
les mots et à l'époque où ipsen l'écrit
c'est c'est tout à fait exceptionnel
c'est un peu comme si déjà il ya ben ça
c'est un peu une écriture pour le cinéma
en fait voilà qui sort assez j'ai trop
parlé là voulaient bien entendu la lah
du 13 janvier au 5 mars à l'odéon qui
est toujours boulevard berthier comme
hiver absolument
voilà merci sa belle voix
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et maintenant
mais
[Musique]
si angelina jolie kolingba et libertés
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir bonsoir ça va bonsoir alors je
vous reçois après brad pitt et matt
damon et je me demande qui reste à
hollywood parce que tous les toutes les
stars sont en france je n'ai pas peur de
faire cambrioler là-bas pendant que vous
n'êtes pas là n'ont rien à voler de son
chili alors l'hiver votre votre mère est
française vous parler français vous avez
parlé mais on s'est ainsi bien c'est
bien là déjà
angelina votre mère est française vous
parler français et non j'apprends
j'apprends le français doivent-ils tiens
oui dommage
vous êtes ici pour alexandre d'oliver
stone avec vous angelina jolie colline
farrell val kilmer jared leto anthony
hopkins christopher plummer et ça sort
le 5 janvier 2005 voilà alors le pitch
bas c est un péplum psychologique qui
raconte comment le jeune roi de
macédoine alexandre a changé la face du
monde par ses conquêtes tollé mais a dit
en parlant d' alexandre ces échecs sont
plus grands que les réussites de la
plupart des hommes c'est quelque chose
qui sera à côté de la chose c'est que
ils voulaient tous il voulait un monde
je crois un monde n'avait qu'un roi bien
sûr c'est lui mais il faut comprendre
qu'il a apporté la paix aussi parce
qu'on se battre il y la personne battait
sauf contre lui alors il a organisé une
société mondiale et après qu'il est mort
c'était riche ça devenus plus riches et
finalement ça devenu le prototype pour
l' empire roman alors le film commence
convoi alexandre qui agonise sur son lit
de mort à babylone à l'âge de 33 ans
flash back en france d'alexandre dont la
mère et angelina vous jouez le rôle de
la merde
deux collines farrell d'alexandre et ont
dit qu'elles se seraient unis à zeus
sous la forme d'un serpent pour enfanter
alexandre et alexandre serait à un
demi-dieu d'une certaine façon c'est ce
qu'elle croyait en fait quand on se
penche sur sa vie en fait elles avaient
toutes les raisons de croire qu'il était
vraiment particulier
en fait elle pratiquer les rites de
dionysos et c'était intéressant de voir
quelle époque
en fait c'était une femme qui comprenait
pas vraiment toute cette histoire de
reproduction en fait à penser à zeus
elle croyait que tout cela avait à voir
avec la production précisément donc
alexandre sera un demi dieu
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
alors ensuite on assiste à l'éducation
d'alexandre et son précepteur ventre les
contacts physiques entre hommes c'est à
dire qu'en fait alexandre aime les
hommes adorent les mecs oui aimer les
gens ayant dit culture il mais la
philosophie les mais la littérature il
aimait l'art il aimait le théâtre la
musique était toujours entouré d'acteurs
de musiciens mais les hommes et ça fait
partie de la culture ça faisait partie
de la culture les potes les hommes à les
coucher ensemble c'est tout à fait
normal et donc alexandre effectivement
été quelqu'un qui aimait tant les hommes
que les femmes
alors voilà le film raconte l'assassinât
de son père la montée du trône à l'âge
de 20 ans et puis les conquêtes l'asie
mineure l'egypte quand ils fondent
alexandrie il ya les normes bataille de
go gamelle cinquante mille soldats
d'alexandre contre cinq cent mille
soldats du roi darius de perse très
belle bataille un brave oliver est très
bien réalisé l'arrêt nadia et puis après
ils arrivent à babylone et là il devient
extrêmement dictatorial
et dépravé 1 il épouse une métisse et
leur après donc ils poursuivent jusque
jusqu en inde jusqu au gange et là il ya
une bataille contre des éléphants il
n'avait jamais vu défendre leur vie les
soldats s'arrêtent ils vont aux indes
ils ont assez on veut rentrer dit non
alors il qu il est avec raison
il y tue 13,2 les mêmes outils mais
après ça il va dans la bataille et les
hommes ne suit pas et c'était une vraie
histoire
alexandre était terriblement blessé aux
seins de passe il a eu une flash dans le
le poumon et son cheval bucéphale qui
meurent aussi et voilà vous connaissiez
l'histoire d'alexandre avant de tourner
le film angelina c'est tout ce qu'il a
fait alors qu'il était jeune qu'il était
vraiment unique
c'était remarquable non mais c'est vrai
que j'ai beaucoup appris en faisant ce
film est un jeu j'en sais beaucoup
maintenant et vous moi j'ai cru qu'ils
étaient russes au départ est présent
sari très peu de choses sur la vie tu le
connais c'est un personnage d'antiquités
qui s'appelait alexandre le grand caire
et qui effectivement conquis 95% d'un
monde moderne où zoran modernes de
l'époque il est beaucoup de recherches
faites sur lui et des milliers de livres
des millions de pages écrites sur lui
c'était des grands page de l'histoire
qui ont été écrites sur ce personnage
mais tous ces livres vous donne une idée
de ce qu'il a été
des émotions attribue ces psychologies
du contenu de qu'il était comme sommes
donc ils étaient de nature j'étais
écrivain il a beaucoup fait vous dit
oliver stone alexandre m'a fait croire
aux héros est ce que vous pensez que
c'est le plus grand héros de tous les
temps on peut pas faire de comparaison
on peut seulement dire que l exemple
c'est un homme le original
unis qui a pas eu un homme comme ça dans
tous l'histoire napoléon jeu 6e ils ont
manqué ils ont tous admirent est grande
chrome chrome et personne a doublé son
record ne jamais perdre une barre à
éloigner tous ces batailles même en se
sacrifiant dans le presque le dernier il
ait jamais été battu dans la vie combien
de fois on est battu tout le monde
croyab et il est extra ti stratégiques
qu'il était génie mais en même temps il
était malin parce que quand il prend un
pays il n'était pas predator est inclus
il fait des vagues
l'inclusion cité par exemple américains
en irak 1couper l'armée irakienne
comment un gel fera jamais quelque chose
comme celui de rémy de son côté il était
très malin et toujours des alliances il
faisait pas ce qu'il voulait faire un
empire du monde entier sans frontières
pense à ça c'est impossible maintenant
mais pense un d'idées originales
1 alors maintenant on va voir à quoi ça
ressemble vous allez regarder tous les
trois votre caméra celle où il ya la
lumière rouge et vous dites
magnéto serge petiteau saint-renan all
together les mauvais temps émis 1 2 3
vannes est incertaine
[Musique]
mais un seul colosse
on ne naît pas roi on le devient
[Musique]
que ferais tu si tu parvenait au bout du
monde
jamais on ne reverra un alexandre
quelques mois alexandre le grand
terminez votre peur
et je vous promets que vous saurez plus
fort que la mort les dieux savent chaque
et l'orgueil des mortels homme ou femme
nul ne saurait avoir trop de pouvoirs
autres de beauté sans aller à sa perte
mais lui ne désirez pas la guerre
alexandre il a creusé son jouarre tes
doigts de la licence
ton nom vivre à jamais dans l'histoire
vivre à la première règle de la guerre
et de faire soi même ce que l'on exige
de sésame
non mais jamais de parler comme tu le
fais pas vraiment pire ennemi
j'ai porté dans mon sein et celui qui
sera mon frangin
je vois ces cieux dans ton regard
repayer mois cette fois ci il faut être
fort pour gouverner tout ce que tu
désires le monde entier est à toi
ne l'oubliera jamais
quand tout est fini seul importe ce que
nous avons fait avec angelina jolie et
collins qui sont les invités ce soir
[Applaudissements]
alors alexandre le brand était roi du
monde à 25 ans il pouvait avoir tout
l'amour qu'il voulait tout l'argent
qu'ils voulaient et malgré tout c'est
quelqu'un d'assez solitaire non et vous
m'en garde y opposant la déco sur
alexander
oui effectivement c'est vrai ce que j'ai
appris plusieurs reprises par nos
conseillers militaires c'est que en
étant leader on s'isoler et avec
alexandre ya cette idée effectivement
qu'il faut être seul pour être un leader
lillois il est devenu l'un des hommes
les plus puissants du monde c'est
également l'un des plus seul se battre
pour retrouver l'amour il a dû répondre
à ces questions de test mais tout ça est
un prix énorme et le prix de 2 c de tous
ses succès ça a été la solitude oui ça
c'est clair
quand on est une star d'hollywood est ce
qu'on est solitaire aussi ça fait aussi
que s'ils sentent plus chez moi je passe
d'un hôtel à un autre
autant dire ce qu'il a dit là qui dit
pas sale non mais c'est vrai que les les
les grandes stars sont les grandes stars
sont très solitaire un peu comme
alexandre moi je m'entoure de gens à gré
entre bon c'est vrai
[Applaudissements]
mais il ya tellement de gens qui se sont
sentis seuls alors qu'ils étaient
entourés d'une vingtaine de personnes
tout simplement parce que parce qu'il
n'avait pas déposé un ami tyreke toi
avec lesquels il avait pourrait relation
autour de caen une faille chez son amant
est mort oui
à l'exemple des morts huit mois plus
tard oui parce que j'aimais c'était le
seul qui les met son corps a été cassé
un sur wii alors évidemment on vous dit
que vous êtes bien l'entourer vous
n'êtes pas seuls on vous a prêté colin
farrell des liaisons avec les plus
belles stars d'hollywood a dit ça j'ai
dit j'ai dit quelque chose il est touché
quelque chose que j'avais pas dire non
non vous dites gbi folio l'actrice milla
jovovich ah oui on vous a prêté des
liaisons avec les plus grandes stars
d'hollywood des mi-mouche britney spears
et même angelina jolie est ce que c'est
à leur stand
ouais avec angelina ccc vrai collines
entourant certaines j'aimerais bien pas
je sais tout
vous dites que vous n'avez pas eu
d'histoire sérieuse depuis cinq ans mais
vous prenez très au sérieux votre votre
rôle de père maintenant ça c'est pas
vraiment le genre de rôle qu'on peut
prendre à la légère
donc mon gentil petit garçon angelina
vous aussi votre fils arrive en tête de
vos préoccupations non c'est ici avec
moi mais là maddox et là aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui votre fils c'est votre
préoccupation première non c'est la
chose la plus importante pour vous ah
ouais absolument c'est sur wii vous
dites dans alexandre j'aurais du mal à
jouer le rôle de la mère d'alexandre si
j'étais pas devenue la maman de maddox
vraiment c'est vraiment une mère et
c'est vraiment ce qu'elle sait qu'une
aire je crois que les fait d'être parent
eh bien on peut pas l'imaginer
intellectuellement il faut en fait
ressentir les choses c'est impossible de
prétendre entre parents dont je connais
très bien les choses oui c'est pour ça
que mon rôle était possible alors c'est
parce que vous vous concentrer sur votre
enfant que vous avez pu vous dites
uniquement des amants de passage
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
maintenant j'avais plus envie d'avoir
une histoire qui dure avec un homme
parce que maintenant votre homme c'est
votre fils à mm monfils oui je n'ai
qu'un seul amour voilà c'est ça c'est
comme ma femme avec son fils alors quand
vous parlez de vos âmes angelina vous
dites en ce moment j'en ai deux
ce sont deux hommes merveilleux je passe
du bon temps avec eux j'espère qu'il
s'amuse aussi avec moi mais c'est juste
for fun i just for fun plaisir
en fait c'est vraiment une relation
entre deux adultes pas mariés deux
adultes qui étaient ici d'avoir une
telle relation c'est qu'ils sont très
bons amis oui on en a vraiment des
bonnes relations sexuelles elle tend le
cache cache coquine ouais vous avait
démenti toute relation avec brad pitt
parce que vous avez dit j'ai acda mangez
pas besoin de brad
je sors pas avec des hommes mariés vous
faites pas les hommes mariés mes bras
c'est vraiment quelqu'un de super oui
vous avez tourné un film avec lui vous
venez de tourner un film qui s'appelle
meester et demie 6 smif et vous avez
déclaré après le tournage du film brad
pitt est un grand du baiser il fait ça
très bien
billy bob thornton en l'an 2000 vous
vous êtes fait tatouer son nom sur le
bras
1 le tattoo il n'est ni bon ni mauvais
et comme vous avait divorcé en 2003 vous
avez fait enlever au laser
ja on y alors aujourd'hui vous allez me
dire si c'est vrai aujourd'hui vous avez
écrit à la base de la nuque ici je sais
pas si c'est vrai mais je trouve ça
tellement extraordinaire qu honnête et
droit en lettres gothiques c'est vrai
mais c'est tout oui mais pourquoi vous
avez écrit ça angelina ce que j'ai
commencé à apprendre des choses sur la
politique des droits de l'homme ce qui
se passe dans le monde et je crois que
c'est vraiment la chose la plus
importante pour nous de savoir il faut
qu'on sache il faut qu'on en dise aux
autres il faut que tout le monde se bat
pour ça alors vous avez sur le soleil
sur l'épaule gauche d'actions dalet
schoder sur l'épaule gauche je l'avais
s'incline d'un texte bouddhiste c'est
vrai et ça dit quoi
qu'est ce que ça dit c'est vraiment bien
pour la france pour protéger votre
famille votre pays votre culture etc
d'accord vous avez des tatouages vous
collez non non offrir aux tatouages dans
le magazine angelina et angie n'a besoin
ni soyaux et ziani soyaux dans le
magazine allure en novembre 2004 aliot
remember vous avait confessé être
intéressé par le sadomasochisme sm
vous dites jeunes et pourquoi pas
extraordinaire mais qu'est ce que vous
avez
nous on a un fois ici ça tombe bien et
vous avez dit j'aime repousser mes
limites émotionnel et sexuelle
je n'ai jamais été attaché mais je sens
que la personne à qui je laisserais
faire ça sera la bonne
je pense que j'adorerais ça c'est vrai
oui
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
merci
je vais vous dire une chose vous appelez
angelina jolie mais vous auriez dû vous
appelez angélina super rebelle
[Musique]
vous voulez l'adopter
vous voulez m'adapter non
[Musique]
2,5 vers ses tubes et note la cour
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
quand
j'accueille laurent baffie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça va le nom est bien toi tu avais le
casting de folie qui a sapé nations là
incroyable c'est incroyable tout
hollywood et dans les couloirs il se la
pète un peu faute ou dégagez faut pas
passer par l'ama temps comment il se la
pète
j'éclate et deux gardes du corps là tu
peux les voir je suis éclaté batta je
vais dit en anglais héros des quotas non
[Applaudissements]
et
j'accueille julie john rech
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça te va très bien je crois non mais
c'est très très très charmant naissance
au printemps
quoi un garçon une fille on sait déjà
il paraît que tu avais des couilles à
l'échographie mais tu prenais regardes
et tu préfère garder la surprise des
savanes et la sauce madère
non la super bon si tu viens pour un
film le polichinelle dans le tiroir
ça commence fort
non il faut dire que judith est déjà la
maman d'un d'un petit noé dont le papa
est dany boon et l'année dernière après
la séparation vous aviez déclaré faire
des concessions des sacrifices c'est
dans ma nature mais on a beau se
convaincre que le monde ne tient qu'à
une seule personne c'est pas vrai voilà
donc toujours des phrases aussi long way
home trainer est en fait pas du tout
c'est à dire qu'un an après avoir dit ça
vous êtes enceinte vous avez vite changé
d'avis quand la main tout de suite fait
un oui sert à financer rapidement oui
c'est un très bon temps savoir c'est
quoi non c'est de l'autre toilette
[Rires]
ouais c'est ça sent jusqu'à ouais moi je
veux leur attrait des bleus pense que
c'est dû à quoi
c'est la grossesse qui existait sur mon
chien non sérieux avec des siens si j'ai
dit pour quelqu'un qui avait dit le
chabada on peut pas voilà plus jamais ça
d'une certaine pas réduire le monde à
une seule personne que pour quelqu'un
qui avait dit ça vous avez vite repiqué
au truc c'est tout ce que je veux dire
qu'on veut pas dire plus jamais ça et
puis ya même des gens qui retombent
amoureux à 70 ans il faut toujours
croire à l'amour et au renouvellement à
la renaissance et et voila voila ca pas
mis longtemps voilà c'est ce que je
voulais dire quoi non mais tant mieux
pour vous oui ce n'est pas farouche en
bref pas du tout maintenant mais si je
peux
sa fille facile je dis que quand je dis
que quand on a je dis pas ça je dis que
quand on a une nature jeudi quand on a
une nature amoureuse et féconde
effectivement on est rapidement amoureux
ont fécondé et féconde et voilà tout ce
que je voulais bien alors on est on est
surtout féconde parce que le corps sans
que c'est là à mon avis la bonne
personne voilà ces personnes d'accord
c'est pas des paillettes carlao martin
valent toutes les demies n'y a pas de ya
pas de côté à canal c'était des jeunes
parents n'y a pas de règle
[Musique]
et parfois ça me manque
ouais car ils glissaient parfois alors
on a le droit de dire que le papa c'est
maurice barthélémy je crois que je crois
que tout le monde le sait non il m'a
même pas prévenu que non parce que c'est
maurice barthélémy des robins des bois
voilà on peut dire ou alors ça fait
partie de la vie privée vous me dites
sinon le couple montage l'on dirait
montage c'est que marc ici c'est tous
les robins des bois
non c'est que maurice d'accord c'est que
maurice ou parce que des fois on baissé
lorsque vous sortez qu'avec des comics
vous le savez quand même extraordinaire
en même temps c il se présente pas comme
ça enfin c'est pas des gens qui
séduisent forcément avec leur humour
ouais enfin quand on s'est rencontrés
c'était pas cette semaine nous a fait
rire non mais c'est pas voyez c'est pas
une tare mais cherchez pas les comics
présent vous cherchez pas un plan à
trois avec avec ramzy woman of surrender
espanès nom stéphane collaro sortir jeu
s'arrêtera stéphane collaro je crois que
c'est quand même ce qu'on peut faire de
faux minute de silence pour ce n'est pas
la serbie peu ce qui s'est passé tu as
vu alors vous êtes ici ce soir judith
pour un film qui s'appelle tu vas rire
mais je te quitte j'avoue que le titre
est assez génial de philippe harel
sortie le 5 janvier 2005 alors le pitch
dû faire le pitre où les classes le
pitch très bien alors le pitch chaque
année du fait de ses piques
le pitch est l'histoire d'une comédienne
blonde sexy un peu nunuche qui partage
son temps entre des tournages de sites
comme halak on peut bien dire et des
dîners trop arrosée entre filles et bref
à 30 ans contrairement à vous elle ne
croit plus au prince charmant voilà
maintenant on y croit encore oui mais
enfin elle fait pas grand chose pour le
trouver quand même si elle fait trop de
choses même pour le trouver enfin se
bourrer la gueule avec ses copines la
plupart du temps elle couche aussi pas
mal
elle touche beaucoup les couches bocoum
avec des mecs sans espoir parce que le
photographe là franchement c'est pas le
genre de mec qu'on épouse un nom le
philosophe alain gal philosophe et un
moment elle tombe sur un philosophe
alors on n'en parlera pas ce que c'est
intéressant comme c'est un vieux je me
sens concerné évidemment alors vous êtes
parfaite dans le rôle à je vais vous
dire vous êtes une bonne comédienne je
vous le dis comme ça la télévision et
avec michèle laroque et marina foïs vous
êtes dans mon panthéon des actrices qui
sont à la fois joli et drôle voilà je
n'attends donc
alors c'est un film assez juste sur la
vie d'actrice finalement parce que
présentent les problèmes d'argent nous
on sait pas ça mais les actrices
évidemment des problèmes d'argent comme
tout le monde ce qui fait que souvent
elles acceptent des rôles un peu moins
bien et c'est non ça c'est bien vu ça
dans le film
oui et non mais c'est vrai que la
majeure partie des acteurs galère c'est
vrai que c'est pas ce dont on parle
qu'elle fait partie de cette majeure
partie c'est-à-dire qu'elles acceptent
des rôles nul pour avoir de l'argent
pour gagner de l'argent pour payer son
loyer et que à force de ne pas
travailler elle est bien obligée de mais
en même temps elle a elle n'est pas très
sympa qui avait pas cultiver c'est
qu'elle n'a pas une éducation forcément
qui fait qu'elle sait comment gérer sa
carrière par exemple pour son book
elle fait des photos en culotte ne
serait pas forcément évident est bon
c'est vrai qu'à priori les metteurs en
scène ne vous demande pas forcément de
s'intéresse pas aux actrices en tout cas
vous à votre saoul quand il essaie de
trouver quelqu'un pour un rôle
oui quand elle fait des castings des
fois elles durent banon vous me faites
chez pl ce cas squale est pas très
politique qu'on dirait voilà pas du tout
politique
elle elle parle sans réfléchir elle met
les pieds dans le plat il a un côté
comme ça assez
maladroite et un peu godiche et qui la
rend drôle forcément puisque c'est une
comédie c'est vrai que c'est un
personnage assez jouissif à regarder
tout à fait puisque quelqu'un qui serait
dans la diplomatie dans la demi mesure
alors on va voir à quoi ça ressemble à
les regarder votre caméra ma caméra
c'est là qu'elle soit loyale rouge et
vous allez accouche coupera le cordon
tu comprends pourquoi je n'arrive pas à
me séparer de lui quand même je les
adore qu'est ce que tu veux que je te
dis donc pour garder une heure tu es en
train devenir neutre là il est en train
de vie actuel permet à givisiez brèche
tu as 28 ans ya tout est adepte de
naissance il ya tous les teams qui date
celle là ça fait des études avaient des
secteurs ruraux à paris avant comme si
c'est ça parce que j'ai étude en trois
temps il aura droit de l'est je voulais
vous débarrasser de lisbourg regarder
votre caméra et vous dites
magnéto serge et puis c'est réglé
d'accord magnéto serge au festival
d'avignon c'est pas payé c'est du rail
mais la fda food mc saïda bull tout ce
que je vois ça vous fait passer une
audition pour un truc chiant quand même
pas payer en mai où ça va pas la tête
celui est possible que ce cri olivier
j'ai plus envie d'une victoire
je ne veux plus vivre avec toi t'es
chiant tu es jaloux terra d'un tu te
lèves tôt et a aucune opinion sur rien
je m'ennuie c'est tout
comme olivier d'abord abollivier c'est
fini on va te présenter mon nouveau mec
parce que tu as déjà un nouveau mec
ensemble je te présente delphine à ma
meilleure amie
hu a commenté bob là dessus le type qui
passe son temps à photographier des
nanas moitié impôts et complète
s'attendre à ce qu'il quitte un peu
moins combative elle sauf que delphine
elle est pas mannequin déjà oui bon on
va pas se laisser abattre
non mais vous savez monica - faut
vraiment je travaille quitte à refaire
un site comme tu es moche je répète
c'est encore une fois je te fout une
tartine pas compétent ménage avec cette
femme c'est raide après ce petit con
tous les jours mais ça me regarde bordel
ça me redonne chez moi j'ai des douleurs
au dos et insupportable bar-lev ta
chemise ce sera plus facile mais rien
qui marche dans ma vie c'est râteau sur
râteau
en fait tu te souviens même et bien
bamako et moi c'est non on se parle mois
prochain tandis qu'à paris comme l'a
écrit bah ouais forcément les grosses au
sens restreint mémoire et à part les
nichoirs et en est quitte je finis par l
avec judith godrèche sortie le 5 janvier
les dames messieurs
alors voilà à un moment elle oublie les
mecs de sa génération elle tombe
amoureuse d'un d'un vieux un philosophe
qui lui dédicace un livre il est vieux
mac il ya au moins un mandat ça ah ouais
et alors après le mec il passe un
bouquin un bouquin de philosophie qu'il
a écrit qu'il était comme ça alors il
lui dit vous l'avez lu qu est ce qu elle
répond je sais pas allé un peu mal à
l'aise finalement elle finit par lui
dire qu'elle a commencé mais franchement
elle comprend rien quoi lancer leur mère
donc voilà et du coup elle était venue
pour coucher avec lui elle espérait
vivre une idylle et elle pensait que
c'était un peu l'homme idéal est lui
très vexé lui dit que avant de coucher
avec elle il faudrait déjà qu'elle
commence par avoir quelque chose dans la
tête
ok 120 et il lui dit je te préviens je
te baserait pas elle ressort ni lui dit
je te préviens je te donnerai pas dit ça
m'étonnerait c'est vrai que je fêterai
comédie anglo saxon et et le personnage
féminin est assez surprenant parce
qu'elle a par moments à ces bimbos par
maman assez enfantine
et c'est un personnage assez surprenant
mais là vous souvenez pas ce genre de
problème vous avez fondé une famille
maintenant avec en main
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais quand vous étiez petit vous
fantasmez sur les clowns déjà non ah
ouais c'est l'info et j'étais amoureuse
d'alexis gruss à voyez bah voila voila
tout tu vois cette émission tout finit
par s'expliquer vous n'êtes pas peur
qu'il soit chauve le petit là n'ont pas
pu honorer les oreilles quand même
maintenant j'ai peur de rien ah bon vous
êtes pas vous n'êtes pas inquiète non
non et vous lui faites reconnaît les
oreilles le fils de dany boon
non mais non il n'a pas les oreilles
décollées ça s'intitule comment vous
langer vous biberonné wauja l'êtes vous
allaitez là maintenant c'est l'heure
vous avez lu tous les livres de
françoise dolto françoise dolto mais
winnicott surtout way to c'est un peu
inquiétant c'est la mère de carlos donc
quand elle donne des conseils sur
l'élevage des enfants c'est un peu seul
élevage des enfants dériot s'il a grandi
et des barbelés autour
ses frères sa donc le film s'appelle tu
vas rire mais je te quitte donc on va
faire une interview tu vas rire mais
[Musique]
judith godrèche est ce qu'on vous a déjà
dit tu vas rire mais attends faut se
mettre mes oreilles d'abord est ce qu'on
refusait a déjà dit et ce qu'on faisait
déjà dit tu vas rire mais je croyais
vraiment que tu t'appelais gros derche
nom n'a pas tellement fait à l'école
saint barbe à baffie que ce que tu fais
enfin merde et la pression à avoir
en fait tu fais des jeux de mots avec
mon nom c'est deux cônes quand j'ai fait
nulle part ailleurs j'avais 17 ans et
c'était godrèche gold rem et hommage au
ballet joly parce que c'était un gode
j'imagine en plus si quand même je suis
assez jeunes dans les écoles moitié
s'agisait les journaux ah bon ouais ça a
changé quand même est-ce qu'on vous a
déjà dit tu vas rire mais je suis pas
vraiment robin des bois non ce qu'on
vous a déjà dit tu vas rire mais tu
m'excite pas du tout non à moi non mais
au personnage dans le film ray natoye
jamais à moi non est ce qu'on a déjà
fait ce qu'on peut est ce qu'on vous a
déjà dit qu'il va rire mais je
préférerais que tu de thèse non jamais
mais non est ce qu'on vous a déjà dit tu
vas rire mais c'est la première fois que
ça m'arrive franchement je comprend pas
ouais sacré maurice et est-ce qu'on vous
a déjà dit qu'il va rire mais je te
trompe avec ta meilleure amie
non mais dans le film ça arrive aussi
ouais mais c'est bien parce que élise le
personnage ici mais pas une fille
rancunière ma main pas du tout non on
qu'elle revient copine immédiatement
avec sa meilleure amie et même l
recouche avec le garçon qui l'a trompée
c'est une fille pleine de joie de vivre
c'est vrai est ce qu'on vous a déjà dit
tu vas rire mais j'ai pas d'argent pour
payer de ristolas ouais ouais
est ce qu'on vous a déjà dit qu'il va
rire mais grâce à toi je suis devenu au
mot
non non tu vas rire mais je suis dany
boon c'est pas mickey moussa n'importe
quoi et cela vous a déjà dit tu vas rire
mais je suis marié ouais ouais ça vous
est arrivé ça souvent non mais une fois
pour toutes est ce qu'on vous a déjà dit
tu vas rire mais je te quitte
ouais j'étais tout petit et ça m'a
marqué j'aime bien remise du prix du
baril
m
j'accueille gilbert montagné
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir bonsoir
enfin tout le monde bonsoir
cette série alors gilbert et gilbert
gilbert thierry cadet faire un tour en
plus parce que tu vois rien non mais moi
j'étais con et tu crois je suis pas
reconnu ma chaîne non non a dit moi
sérieux là on a reçu une dépêche afp
jeudi dernier tu vas commencer demain
une grève de la faim au nom des aveugles
baisse et c'est assez grave en fait
j'aurais aimé venir vous faire marrer
mais là je suis pas sur la base'' quand
même dans le sens où dont moi j'étais
tranquille je me regardais un film en
noir et blanc bon normal tu veux et puis
j'ai eu un coup de téléphone non suivant
j'ai eu un coup de téléphone de la plus
grande association des non voyants qui
m'ont demandé si je pouvais les aider
parce que il ya un problème très
important sur la nouvelle loi sur les
handicapés
alors je vous vois vous et vous qui êtes
chez vous 2 aujourd'hui cap et maison et
l'aurait déjà non il faut pas que ce
soit un sujet qui paraît chiant parce
que ça n'a rien de chiens du tout il ya
six millions et demi d'handicapés dieu
alors la loi
la dernière loi était de 75 donc c'est
très important que la nouvelle loi soit
en adéquation avec notre évolution et
avec avec ce qu'on veut pour le mieux
vivre alors le problème c'est que dans
cette loi c'est il ya les acquis et qui
qui sont beaucoup moins importants
finalement que dans l'ancienne donc si
c'est pour une nouvelle loi
ouais on perd des trucs sa part qu
est-ce qu on perd c'est la question qui
seront perd on perd
les gens par exemple qui touchent une
pension compensatrice pour les aider
dans leur vie de tous les jours
la pension qui sera versé à ces gens-là
dont je fais partie pas pour la pension
mais parce que je suis indiqué p tit peu
petit peu seulement
et bien la pension sera beaucoup moins
importante qu'elle l'est actuellement
donc ça c'est un peu n'importe quoi
quand même connerie effectivement de
faire une nouvelle loi tu vois pour
donner moins d'argent
un petit peu c'est ce qu'on m'a expliqué
alors deuxième point il demande
à ce que les déficients visuels qui ont
travaillé pendant 30 ans il arrive à 55
ans et puissent partir en retraite avec
leur taux plein ce afin son plein on
veut l'audiovision alors l'audiovision
c'est drôlement cool ce truc là c'est un
d un supplément audio quand tu regarde
un film par exemple tu regardes à moi
aussi je suis à la maison je regarde un
film je suis sérieux je regarde un film
je vais adorer l'histoire je peux te
raconter l'histoire d'un adulte et tu me
dire au fait que c'était une telle vue
ben je sais pas l'aspect ya pas le titre
ça s'appelle gilberte sapène
l'audiovision que sur un canal
particulier je voudrais quelqu'un
numérique ça doit être facile exactement
canal particulier il ya quelqu'un qui
raconte en fait ce qu'on ce qu'on voit
sur l'écran la wii et les présentèrent
ajouté
oui ça marche très bien dans certains
pays par rapport à beaucoup de pays
européens
complètement l'audiovision ça fait 3
après après on va s'aimer lé 4 en ligne
[Applaudissements]
et le quatrième point mais pas des
moindres c'est que moi je trouve qu'il
ya à peu près il ya vingt ans que je dis
c'est ça m'énerve parce que je répète
toujours les mêmes choses et c'est pour
ça que je craque et que je me suis mis
aussi avec eux hors dow est comme on dit
en français le quatrième point c'est que
j'en ai un petit peu marre du fait qu'
on soit obligé quand tu es dans la rue
tu as besoin de d'argent tu as oublié du
tablier de prendre du blé tu arrives à
une distributrice way des à bab al vient
distributeurs automatiques de billets
voilà alors tu dis ah ben c'est bien
comment je commence je la joue là parce
que ça parle pas il n'y a absolument
aucun moyen pour que je puisse penser à
venir entendre aveugle de la
distributrice
excuse moi mais judicaire en train de se
rendre compte tu vois ce que ça doit
être quand tu es aveugle et tu vas un
distributeur de billets bonjour je dis
je vous ai même pas s'afficher sur mme
royal sa as
[Applaudissements]
j'ai les yeux voilà oui donc tu sais pas
sur quel camp tu appuies mais on a aucun
moyen il ya aucun moyen de savoir ce qui
se passe et aucun moyen de prendre
l'argent alors ça m'est même arrivé moi
d'avoir oublié de prendre du blé est
d'être dans un taxi et de lui dire
écoutez monsieur voulait venir avec moi
le mec je lui donne ma carte
il la met dans la machine et puis
évidemment vous julian le code parce que
parce que parce que je peux pas le
machine est donc peut-être faut juste de
l'argent avec aussi parce qu'on sait et
c'est pas possible de supporter une
chose comme ça alors moi je comprends
pas pourquoi la banque de france n'a
jamais bougé à ce sujet là la banque
centrale européenne n'a jamais bougé à
ce sujet là on n'entend pas l'impossible
on ne manque de pouvoir fonctionner
beaucoup mieux que ça et attend la
distributrice de faim je dis attention
attendez je vous parle à tout le monde
je suis serein il n'y a personne ils
sont tous pareils et la distributrice de
billets mes potes qui sont sur fauteuil
roulant ils peuvent pas non plus touchés
parce que elle est trop haute
eh oui donc on est tous à la rue avec ça
alors je dis moi je veux pas je ne sais
pas une histoire de droite gauche si
soir la manche puisque on devrait
pouvoir obtenir le consensus politique
sur les solutions à apporter aux
handicapés parce que c'est quand même
pas compliqué et si on n'a pas de
contacts six personnes nous contactent
d'ici quelques heures
je vois pas comment on va pouvoir faire
autrement gilbert de là tu as vraiment
vers une grève de la faim absolument
mais moi c'est cesser les potes aveugle
qui veulent le faire
ouais et moi je vais être je suis
solidaire parce que tu attends je vais
pas dire je suis solidaire avec vous et
puis pour la grève de la faim ben non
moi je me faire le foie gras et machin
va possible et pas la jouer comme ça
donc j'espère qu'on va pas en arriver là
parce que je trouve c'est une ineptie
alors qu'on demande très très peu de
choses on demande simplement
et bonne nouvelle on vous demande pas
d'argent ce soir de l'amour simplement
de l'amour
alors que je vous demande si vous
trouvez que ça a du sens que je viens de
vous dire a envoyé quelques mails à
droite à gauche ça serait pas bête que
les non handicapés soit vraiment
solidaires avec nous parce qu'on est
dans ce monde là tous ensemble ces sales
histoires inventer des actions bravo
merci merci à vous merci
oui
[Musique]
les distributeurs de billets à l'audio
vision quand on regarde la télévision
la retraire que des trucs bien grève de
la faim parce qu'il a deux trois kilos à
perdre et non mais c'est vrai
j'accueille richard seff
bonsoir je connaissais gilles godrèche
comme tout le monde richard certes vous
êtes avec votre frère daniel parmi les
meilleurs songwriter français vous avez
commencé à écrire des chansons en 1969
premier contrat d'artiste en 70 sur la
recommandation de claude nougaro dont
nous recevrons les pouces juste après
vous est aujourd'hui la meilleure façon
de vous présenter c'est d'écouter
quelques chansons que vous avez fait
avec votre frère didier
[Applaudissements]
jeudi m
j'épouse ma tête sur mon épaule et je
chante
je pose ma tête sur ton épaule et je
chante les jours
je
roma
pour m
[Musique]
attention
quito
[Musique]
entraide
je t'attends
temps je tête
[Musique]
la can
vu ce que
parfois
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voilà richard sève est là messieurs
alors non je n'ai fait pleins ça c'est
juste un c'est juste un échantillon
j'avais dû gagner plein de bébés quand
même temps c'est que des tubes j'ai pas
de nous plaindre on peut pas me
reprocher que je fais un livre au gagne
de l'argent
non non alors justement fait un livre
chez flammarion qui s'appelle la
décadence alors c'est un pamphlet qui
raconte comment le marketing détruit la
création alors le pitch est simple c'est
grandeur et décadence
c'est le cas de le dire d'une vedette de
la téléréalité alors décadence avec un
c'est le titre de la chanson de
gainsbourg dont le héros du bouquin fait
une reprise et décadence avec un e
eh ben vous dit effectivement que la
chanson est revenue à un produit jetable
de nos jours un tout à fait alors c'est
l'histoire d'un jeune toulousain de
vingt ans qui raconte à un ami qui l'a
pas vu depuis longtemps sa participation
à une émission de télé réalité qui est
comparable à love story qui s'appelle
bande à part sur telesis quand il arrive
dans ce loft effectivement ils
découvrent cette chloé est une espèce de
deux filles un peu rebelle comme ça et
puis découvre surtout que le casting a
été très bien fait c'est à dire que
finalement tous les personnages sont là
pour incarner une une typologie
particulière alors site avec chloé quand
soir lors d'une partie karaoké
complètement bourré ils reprennent la
chanson de gainsbourg la décadence si
l'enfant un disque et là vous passez à
une critique très très acerbe et très
documenté il faut bien le dire de
l'industrie du disque vérolé par le
marketing
c'est ce que j'essaie de démontrer c'est
qu'à partir du moment où effectivement
on prend la production à l'envers
c'était qu'on rend les gens célèbres et
puis on les fait chanter ensuite on sent
le disque tout le monde est à peu près
sûrs d'eux
son coût ce qu'on apprend en tous les
cas dans votre bouquin c'est qu'en fait
tous les disques qui n'ont pas reçu
l'approbation d'une radio ne sont même
pas mis en vente quoi oui alors ça c'est
j'étais étonné du nombre de personnes
qui ont étonné de sa or tout le monde
dans le métier est au courant que on
quand je dis que la chanson est traité
comme un produit ça le couvre ces terres
ont fait exactement comme pour un
produit comme un nouveau yaourt une
lessive ont fait un test on appelle
enfin panel soit disant représentatif la
radio appelle souvent au téléphone dès
fois dans des salles de tests marketing
quelques dizaines de personnes à qui
font écouter 8 à 10 secondes
généralement du refrain de la chanson et
les gens doivent eux ap oui non et
généralement ils le font en trois
secondes ce qui veut bien dire que s'ils
ne reconnaissent pas l'artiste aussi le
truc si le team ne ressemble pas à
quelque chose qu'ils ont déjà l'habitude
d'entendre ces ap effectivement on a
beaucoup de mal à passer ensuite d'être
programmé si lyon refilent comme ça des
dire que tous les dix qui sont non
seulement à la radio mais ceux qui sont
mis en vente dans le commerce sont
passés à travers ce filtre là oui parce
que de toute façon c'est très rare de
sortir un disque dans le commerce il a
pas été passée en radio on va très bien
on voit très souvent des singles par
exemple qui sortent on les envoie en
rade hui sont jamais dans le commerce on
attend que ce soit passé suffisamment en
radio pour mais dans le commerce
alors ce que vous racontez c'est que
vincent est clos et donc ils font une
reprise de la décadence de gainsbourg
avec un bon dj ils sont assez contents
et donc ça même plutôt bien et 18 chats
c'est bien et tout ça mais quand ils
entendent le disque à la radio si une
version beaucoup plus plate beaucoup
plus mièvre formaté formaté radio thé
chaque en fait eu la première production
et garder pour les boîtes pour les
collecteurs mais ce qui passe en radio
c'est une version abâtardie quoi si une
version formaté là aussi termes
industriels pour quelque chose qui est
complètement en contradiction avec ce
que doit être une création originale
peut être or le formatage c'est le
contraire en fait quand je hais ce qu'on
appelle formatage c'est essayer de
produire un titre
qui a le plus de chances de passer en
radio en gros en fournit aux radios le
contenu qu'ils attendent et on voit très
souvent d'ailleurs même des remixes qui
sont faits pour telle radio de rakuten
un côté musique un de façon à s'assurer
les passages en fait le formatage ça
amène à choisir le produit qui dérange
le moins exactement mais bien si elles
répondent à l'originalité dites vous
dans vos titres devient devient une tare
la différence devient un défaut car il
faut être couleur couleur muraille quoi
il faut être comme tout le monde
le marketing est en train de je trouve
de faire beaucoup de mal à la création
ce que vous dites c'est que quand les
les maisons de disques 10 bannu
finalement on fait ça c'est vrai mais
avec l'argent qu'on gagne ça nous permet
de produire des jeunes artistes un peu
indépendant et c'est fait c'est pas vrai
du tout moi je trouve ça c'est
l'argument fut pacs et laurine alibi en
fait ouais c'est la libye parce que si
on prend aujourd'hui dans les majeures
les vraies nouveautés c'est à dire
nouveaux artistes signés mais toute
cette année je suis sûr que si on enlève
tous les artistes sortie de star
académie de popstars des aussi de tout
ce qu'on voit moi c'est un peu moins
transparents mais ce qu'on appelle les
partenariats cette dernière des dix que
l'on sorte parce qu'on sait déjà l'avant
ce que telle chaîne de télévision haute
et l'autre vont participer
si on enlève tout ça je voudrais savoir
que la proportion exacte de vrais
nouveaux artistes
c'est là qu'on a signé à l'écouté de
leurs titres ou parce qu'on les a vus
sur scène alors le pire c'est que ça
marche
cher que la reprise mièvre et plates de
la décadence et un succès bien sûr c'est
ça qui était si sûr et et le duo vend
autant que johnny après 40 ans de
carrière il passe chez drucker chez tout
le monde en parle que j'essaie
effectivement de 2 montre aussi c'est
que cette célébrité qui est devenu
aujourd'hui mais un peu l'opium du
peuple moderne c'est à dire que on dit
aux gens soyez célèbre c'est la réussite
absolue l'ébruiter un appartement là
déconnecté de tout ce qui donne un sens
à célébrer le talent le la performance
et l'effort on dit voilà tout le monde a
droit ce fameux quart d'heure de gloire
j'ai l'impression que c'est peut-être la
pire des choses et c'est une façon très
je trouve pernicieuse en plus
deux maîtres de soumettre les gens et
les gens les plus malléables
c'est-à-dire finances est assez facile
de donner un quart d'heure de gloire
justement c'est d'autant plus facile que
ceux qui ont les moyens de la donner
sans ce camp les vrais moyens dans la
société
c'est les mêmes qui ont les médias qui
ont aussi les la presse qui souvent au
fond du bâtiment au fond d'eux de
l'armement donc ont le pouvoir et d'un
côté avant il fallait payer les gens
aujourd'hui on peut même les avoirs sans
les payer
donc après l'émission tout le monde en
parle comme ans pour ce vincent la
descente aux enfers les soirées jet-set
bilan on va chercher des portables la
porsche carrera d'occasions le come back
raté avec un 10 qui lui tient vraiment à
coeur mais qui est anti commercial et à
ce moment là il ya quelqu'un qui dit
nous sommes une maison de disques notre
métier c'est de vendre du disque qui
c'était s'occuper des artistes ont
s'appellerait maison d'artistes voilà je
vous dirais que c'est que
malheureusement cette phrase est vrai
avant elle est vraie je ne vais pas
inventer
elle a été prononcée dans un séminaire
voilà donc à 23 ans à moitié alcoolique
et notre ami vincent accepte de faire
des galas dans les discothèques et
finalement la seule excuse qui trouva
tout ça c'est de se dire que c'est mieux
que de bosser à l'usiné
ce n'est quand même pas si j'en ai passé
n'ont aidé pas fini pas non plus de gens
qui enfin dans les bas-fonds
effectivement pas ce que ça peu c'est
pas des vies non plus très difficile à
c'est un peu triste et faire des galas
de d d d d d anniversaire de supermarché
ou des choses comme ça mais on peut
gagner assez bien sa vie sans trop
la décadence quand il est là qu il est
il est arrivé bispo non guy a lepage
[Musique]
alors guy a lepage richard je t'explique
qui sait c'est d'abord quelqu'un qui a
fait au québec une émission formidable
qui s'appelait rock et belles oreilles
ensuite il a fait un gars une fille
qu'il a vendu dans 22 pays et france 2 y
lançant la troisième rediffusion d'un
gars une fille donc apparemment c'est
bien et puis surtout il a fait tout le
monde en parle au québec et tout le
monde en parle au québec ça fait 50 3%
de part de marché si tu veux nous ont
fait 30 min et 53 alors il est de
passage à paris
merci d'être là je lui ai demandé d'être
avec lui pour la 200e ça va
félicitations de sa ré 200 à vos excuses
avant laurent baffie ouais non il
s'appelle dany turcotte et non il est
bien japonais a convaincu on fait du
bien non j'aime beaucoup
oui c'est moi qui l'a choisi c'est un
bon choix y est et ouais on s'entend
super bien
c'est quoi son vrai métier à la base
c'est un humoriste d'accord elle c'est
pas comme toi bon maintenant c'est vous
richard qu'ils allaient descendre aux
enfers
on va faire un blindtest télé réalité un
blind test de merde
[Musique]
je suis
pascal jean pascal van persie
j'ai d'abord un truc ça fait des années
que j'ai pas regardé je suis pour mais
justement c'est pour ça qu'on te le fais
et sinon tu aurais tu as you allons-y
didier tous les nids faire pour un mec
bien vu contre la télé la lutte est
nommé koné tous attention didier
qui
c
[Musique]
on sait par qui ce qui se
bah ouais vous vous savez qui c'est
aoued for what were bravo exactement ça
attention didier
[Musique]
à l'aise les l5 bravo c'est toi qui va
souffler c'est toi tu connais ses larmes
que médecin je suis là dessus attention
du 10
il
emma daumas bras connais bien quand même
non ceux les plus connus parce que
j'écoute la radio je vais pas pouvoir
retourner à toulouse moi je pense didier
j'attends
on est la chanson parce que c'est une
reprise c'est une reprise de d'une
chanson des années 80 mais je me suis
surprise de phil barney puis-je barney
et la fille qui chante s'appelle non
mais vous c'est normal
merci didier chimène badi
donc elle a pris pas mal quand même
assez content de moi finalement
finalement très content que pas pouvoir
retourner à toulouse moi je pense
richard c'est la décadence
j'ai publié chez flammarion mesdames
messieurs
et là c'est la rentrée serge ouais ouais
si helena noguerra
[Musique]
et réciter quoi j'aime quand il fait
froid tu vois c'est davantage de l'hiver
parce que moi j'avais hélène nougaro
après juste après elena vient pour le
blind test de la mort tu sais l'amérique
avec l'a2 basket de l'amour chaque fois
bien en arrière comme ça
voici et les loups garous
[Musique]
bonsoir
vous connaissez risque arguments
hélène nougaro voilà un plaisir de
richard seff de toulouse
judith godrèche et guy a lepage qui
présente tout le monde en parle au
québec
voilà avec beaucoup de bonnes ou succès
alors pardon
quand je disais le titre de l'émission
c'est comment romain blanc bien hélène
bonsoir donc c'est la veuve de claude
nougaro décédé en mars dernier et vous
venez ici ce soir pour nous présenter
son album posthume la note bleue qui
sort sur le fameux label blue note
alors avant d'écouter quelques morceaux
du nouvel album on va faire un petit
flashback didier de jazz et la java
soulage bien il ya toujours à temps les
hivers de l'autre
jantes
j'avais la jaxa vous tombez donc jules
mais non jules en nous
[Musique]
mais chaque fois que l'on renifle la
puce de presse du support pour un baiser
pour une gifle à une petite fille en
pleurs dans une ville en plus et moi qui
pourra faire
et moi tu pourras près au milieu de la
nuit
mais qu'est ce que je devais faire sur
les cons noir de mai nuit blanche
où je me
de cinéma une fois deux fois dix fois
vingt fois je recommence la séquence et
c6
ma fille
que se passe-t-il je n'y comprends rien
y avait une ville et ya plus rude je me
souviens que je marche que je marchais
dans une rue au milieu de la cohue sous
un joint du soleil de mai c'était plein
de couleurs ou de mouvements et de bruz
[Musique]
par robert wood
restée
mieux encore que dans la chambre rouge
thème dans la cuisine rien n'est plus
beau que les mains d'une femme dans la
farine
armstrong je ne suis pas noir je suis
blanc de peau aussi
ici
quant à chansons colle à la peau
au mont houy
pan de cailloux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
violence bouillonne jusqu'à galette
quatre boules de cuir tourner dans la
ligne
on a les guéré
ts de pierre
la pluie fait des claquettes sur le
trottoir à minuit
parfois je me casse je l'admirais chaque
lot guy tu verras tu verras tout
recommencera tu verras tu verras l'amour
c'est fait pour saturer
[Musique]
choc
non
ici
[Musique]
nous l'aurons
mais non
énorme
[Applaudissements]
merci y'a pas grand chose à acheter
je dois dire que c'est fabuleux quoi
c'est extraordinaire moi j'ai pris du
plaisir extraordinaire en écoutant ses
chansons j'ai appris à écrire en
écoutant ses paroles c'est magnifique ça
fait très plaisir d'écouter ça moi j'en
connaissais aucune essai de sa jolie
voix là alors maintenant on va écouter
quelques quelques morceaux donc du
nouveau cd qui s'appelle la note bleue
qui sort sur le fameux label blue note
alors évidemment j'imagine que tout
novaro était très heureux quand ça lui a
été proposé de rejoindre le label de
thelonious monk de miles davis ou de
john coltrane non ah oui très très fier
c'est le directeur du label coûts qui
lui a proposé un soir de on était au
bataclan pour aller voir un chanteur
alors il fait d'une famille de chanteurs
lyriques et de pianiste classique mais
très jeune il avait été marqué par par
glenn miller par louis armstrong donc le
jazz c'est d'ailleurs lui qui a fait
connaître le jazz grâce à ses chansons
il l'a popularisé d'une certaine façon
oui en mettant des classiques de jazz
ouais en chance alors on trouve sur ce
disque sur ce nouveau disque disque
posthume donc on trouve un morceau de
d'herbie hancock qui s'appelle
cantaloupe island sur lequel il a il a
écrit les paroles qui était sur yousri
tu sais et puis une reprise en duo de
dansez sur moi avec david linx qui est
un vocaliste belge on va écouter c'est
des chansons didier
c'est sur moi quand c'est sur quoi
ces sources
à
oui
nous
et c'est fini
[Musique]
audi wade
sur les coups je vois
on
c'est moi du monde m
barbe blanchie par mois
[Musique]
souvent
lee
voilà que nogaro le nouvel album
s'appelle la le bleu bien ça aussi
mm
[Musique]
jouer
les shows
[Musique]
m
où
d'une vie
voilà qu'elle nous garons mêmes bleus
alors elle aime sortir sortir ce disque
quelques mois après sa mort ça a dû être
une décision délicate à prendre
j'imagine non oui tout à fait on a
attendu quatre ou cinq mois avant de
reprendre le travail sur l'album mais
bon tu tenais tellement justement ce
qu'est ce que un cd sur ce label
ça va vous faire bizarre d'être à sa
place ici pour être sûrs et là la promo
de l'album non dans la mesure où j'ai on
a décidé de le sortir majeur j'ai
accepté d'en parler
vous avez raison à 100 vous savez
aujourd'hui commencer il faut venir la
télé pour en parler c'est comme ça tout
le monde en parle
tu m entends pas alors claude avait
commencé à travailler sur cet album
avant sa maladie un est en fait une fois
qu'il est tombé malade cela aidait à
celle là aider à vivre l'art l'a aidé à
vivre un peu comme ça a été le cas
pendant sa vie tout à fait novice a
toujours été le cas toute façon il était
où il était ma femme pas malade mais il
est dépressif et c'est vraiment l'art et
la beauté qui l'ont qui ont aidé à vivre
tout le temps alors ce qui est terrible
c'est que l'album a été enregistré en
fait beaucoup de chansons pendant sa
maladie ces repas dansant son traitement
contre le cancer entre une amélioration
et une rechute
il a fait ses voix dans le studio divan
casseurs qui a réalisé l'album
à la maison aussi un petit peu on a
utilisé ses voiles et les voix fait
nougaro n'a jamais fléchi ça se maîtrise
extraordinaire je trouve son dernier
album d'une qualité d'écriture d'une
qualité vocale mais parfaite était quand
même alors que des fois à bord avec la
jeu c'est vrai que ça suis un peu quand
on sait qu'il ya des gens qui enregistre
en studio qui se font re reliques c'est
pour avoir la voix un peu plus juste par
des logiciels jetons que c'est bien
d'entendre un vrai chanteur aussi
[Musique]
alors oui nous est même arrivé de filmer
des séances d'enregistrement et lui
projeté parce qu'il pouvait pas ne
pouvait pas sortir de son lit oui là
c'était tout à la fin oui j'allais au
studio je me ramener des images des
musiciens puisqu'il n'a pas pu en fait
enregistré en même temps que les
musiciens
en tous les cas tous les musiciens à
commencer par yvan cassar qui le
réalisateur d'albums on dit que vous
avez été exemplaire pendant cette
période et même aussi on était exemple
voilà je suis très content du travail
alors claude a dit en parlant de vous
jusqu'à présent j'avais rencontré les
femmes de ma vie avec elle j'ai enfin
rencontré la femme de ma mort il savait
qu'il allait passer le restant de ses
jours avec vous oui j'ai peut être le
côté de 20 des artistes en même temps
quand il disait ça j'étais moyennement
quand vous l'avez rencontré la réunion
je les rencontre à l'île de la réunion
où en mars 84 vous lui avez fait un
massage en fait c'est ça tout à fait et
il a découvert que vous étiez de
toulouse il a su que j'étais de toulouse
avant que je m'efface le massage et ça a
été l'amour tout de suite
ah non non on est là bien entendu déjà
là j'espère oui oui il a eu moins de mal
au dos il m'a invité à son spectacle
puis après en fait il est reparti à
l'île maurice où il m'a appelé cheval et
le rejoindre qu'après avoir partie en
france et là je croyais que je le
reverrai plus et puis il a téléphoné
puis je rentrais à paris c'est la durée
comme un damné 20 en mars 95 mars ils
ont fait des massages
[Musique]
et
m
[Musique]
voilà
voilà un compte et sachez une chose ce
que nous sommes nombreux à penser à lui
à le regretter et l'aisne
voilà c'est tout ce que je peux vous
dire merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non
fait leur entrée voici la grille
oui mesdames messieurs daguise oui voilà
si j'ai la 200e le grondement centièmes
c'est merci d'être là c'est énorme de
sang mais c'est rare une illusion t d
qui dure aussi longtemps c'est vrai fan
moi personnellement je vois tu
recommences le 25 décembre le samedi 25
décembre à 18h50 sur france 2 encore
plus libre et ouais alors c'est quoi ces
unions libres il ya plus de pays
bravo et voilà ça c'est fait et même des
pays qui ne sont pas européens paraît
encore plus comme la turquie par exemple
une ouverture nous les états unis où les
états unis
voilà où est alors citoyens du monde
nous serons donc ça ça commence le 25
décembre 25 30 ans souhaite 200 déjà
pour commencer voyage un voyage est
ensuite il ya un prime qui s'appelle ça
va être votre fête le 28 décembre sur
france 2 ouais ce que tu sais pas c'est
que le chiffre est à moi mais ce pavage
tous les titres honte à toi tu devras
d'épouser bonjour j'ai hélas hélas là
pour les chansons non mais ça va être ta
fête alors je dis officiellement je te
l'offre
évidemment en rien le bas à arrêter
quoi s'arrête 27 c'est à toi ouais mais
non mais oui mais non tu crois qu'on n'a
pas vérifié ça avant mais je te dis que
je rigole on rigole c'est ali arrête que
du doigt les jour du seigneur
aujourd'hui s'énerve
bonjour j'aurais vu des positions on
peut pas plaire à tout le monde j'étais
con way là c'est ballot qu'est ce que je
regrette mais tu t'es dit un titre comme
ça je ne peux pas me satisfaire sa peut
pas marcher gens disent que je relevais
symbole qu'est ce que je regrette je
suis le déposer tiens je vais déposer
aux corinthiens chef kai andré
dussollier
dans la vie vous à regard
avec des yeux j'aimerais tellement
regarde comme ça mais vraiment alors
mais il m'a aidé à me laisser aux femmes
voient oui ouais un bon tour en corse
comme ça c'est fait ça c'est réglé
voilà c'est tout ouais bah oui c'est
recevoir l'ordre alors deux spectacles
au théâtre andrea les athlètes dans leur
tête monstres sacrés sacré monstre
et puis deux films un long dimanche de
fiançailles 36 quai des orfèvres la
réunion avec une promo pareil vénitien
passage dans ocean's twelve on le voit
dans le bar de dos alors on va commencer
par le théâtre 1 vous reprenez au
théâtre de la gaîté montparnasse en
alternance une semaine sur deux par un
jour sur deux monstres sacrés sacrément
on serait athlètes dans leur tête
alors monstres sacrés sacré mons et des
textes de victor hugo de d'alphonse
allais d'alfred de vigny et puis les
sacrément c'est plutôt farceur dubillard
voilà c'est une sorte d'anthologie comme
ça personnel qui est que je me suis
amusé à composer
mais comme une petite pièce de théâtre
qui sera écrite par plusieurs auteurs
vous avez un texte avait envie de faire
ça en vrai la matin de deux monstres
sacrés sacrément j'essaie de me souvenir
et demeureront chez barry sur un petit
texte comme ça qui est en plein milieu
du montage
oui assez court 1 assez court bien que
le morse d'ordinaire soit un animal
débonnaire il ne faut pas trop l'excité
on sait que les morts sont vite quand
quelque chose les irrite rien ne peut
plus les arrêter seul et je ne sais trop
gras ça qu'elle amorce les moujiks en
russie on dit ont le pouvoir de les
faire rentrer soudain dans le devoir
moralité le moujik adoucit les morts qui
est un groupe s'appelait le chat noir et
l'or c'est un des dépôts est de ce
groupe
alors gardons ce sacre est sacrément
soya athlètes dans leur tête donc mise
en scène et interprétation de vous
envoie du soulier sur des textes de paul
fournel alors c'est une espèce de
dommages aux grands sportifs parce que
vous dites
les grands sportifs finalement plus on
les filme - on les connaît s'était
exclamé s'approcher plus près qu'une
caméra ou un micro
oui c'est vrai paul fournel qui connaît
bien le sport et tu connais bien les
sportifs les fait parler comme on les
entend jamais parler et dire des petites
choses comme ça en général les sportifs
c'est vrai il ya toujours un devoir de
réserve ne veulent pas déplaire aux
sponsors à l'entraîneur donc pendant
qu'ils exercent leur passion il parle
pas beaucoup et là paul fournel l'effet
dire des choses intimes de leur
difficulté pour sept petites secondes de
gloire il ya eu beaucoup de souffrance
de doute et c'est très savoureux même si
on connaît pas bien le sport mais c'est
et en plus je me suis amusé à les
représenter en pleine action parce que
de toute façon ils sont décrits en
pleine action il ya le footballeur qui
rate une reprise de volée ou cdc des
petits moments de vie de sportive qui
sont par exemple il ya par exemple le
match om pézilla le joueur qui se met à
gamberger la gamberge c'est pire qu'un
un claquage à penser en jouant au ballon
c'est fini yann jeune boxeur qu'on
essaie de transformer en tueur
professionnel aussi c'est voilà à chaque
fois d'ailleurs on n'est pas toujours
sûr le personnage dont on parle comme
ans le boxeur mais l'entraîneur puis
ensuite le masseur puis ensuite le
sophrologue tous nous tous ces gens qui
s'occupent de lui il va se répandre
comme
comme on le suppose qu'on imagine parce
que souvent que ce soit le tennisman
cyclistes ils repèrent quelqu'un dans le
public comme ça alors par exemple le
cycliste y voit une femme
il imagine qu'elle est nu il se met à
penser à un strip-tease et puis bon
voila il perd quoi c'est oui où il
croise le regard d'une femme comme ça
dont il tombe amoureux puis commencer à
rêver sur elle le tout c'est aussi avec
une bande son qui nous met tout de suite
dans l'ambiance de la bande sur
l'enseigné youg's de tiger woods
championne un contradicteur dans un
compte qu'on ne va pas me prendre mais
c'est vrai la bande son est très bien
eric cdu c'est un show c'est un
spectacle à chaque fois le sport
maintenant donc il ya même il ya même
des commentateurs il ya un elson monfort
qui est là un qui dit quelques phrases
chez sur un joueur de tennis
alors vous aimez pas trop vous dévoiler
voix moi je sais qu'une fois vous êtes
venus ici même raconté par le biais des
rôles pour vous faire avouer qu avec
isabelle adjani ça m'a pris un quart
d'heure vous dites l'hyperconsommation
de la vie réelle des comédiens et
dangereuse quoi ces conneries tu es né à
annecy pourquoi ce choix
elle rendrait on va faire avec une
interview dans la vraie vie c'est normal
[Musique]
alors andré est ce que dans votre vraie
vie il ya des coups de théâtre pour vous
à oui j'adore ça vous arrive comme un
oui oui ouais je sillonne les rues dans
l'espoir qui aura un coup de théâtre on
fait un croisement avec votre femme fait
relâche lundi
non non non et trois quotas prévient
andré s'il te répond ah ça c'est les
trois coups derrière
dans les trois coups non les trois plus
dans la vraie vie vous arrive de vous
jouer la comédie à vous même à moi même
peut-être pas trop non
non au jour toute la journée à bas où ça
peut arriver ouais ça pète le jeu est
assez agréable aussi c'est une
déformation professionnelle dans la
vraie vie vous avez déjà pensé à changer
de partenaire oh oui bien sûr ouais bien
sûr oui ça peut arriver comme ça c'est
facile de rêver un peu passive un nom
quand on la voit alors on peut en salle
est-ce que dans la vraie vie vous
changez souvent de décor oui j'aime bien
ça ouais voyager toute façon même
changer de décor il me suffit de rester
chez moi pour changer de décor assez
facilement est ce qu'il ya eu un long
entracte dans votre couple
attention aux passionnés ce kimono
répond pas ça peut arriver les
entrailles tu mets ça permet de bien
repartir pour la suite
il ya une scène dans la vraie vie que
vous ne vous lassez jamais de jouer en
dhr eh oui le matin au réveil j'adore ça
chaque but auxerrois chapiteau des mots
[Musique]
consacrer 5 de monde
et à fait dans leur famille
je vais vous laisser aller vous coucher
parce que dans notre état oui à coucher
à bientôt qu siens quand on se reverra
il sera n'ayant non tête par quinze ans
peut-être pas la télé ça va ça vient
chez un médecin qui sort le 23 mars le
champion l'universel ah bon alors tu
viens alors
bah ouais avec mathilde seigner anne
parillaud ah oui venez tout ensemble
alors
[Musique]
m
ce nouveau truc on a instauré ici quand
les gens s'en vont les rappels juste
pour les pêcheurs jules dit j'ai dit
judy quoi rêver on oublie une question
bien ouais non j'ai déjà vu l'émission
assez bon d'accord ouais si michel
vergnier
[Musique]
ce dernier qui vient pour le gneiss de
la mort
[Applaudissements]
le petit à petit les équipes se forment
tu veux ma chérie tu es chez toi qu'est
ce qui à melvin qu'est ce qui se passe
et ça passait derrière toi je t'ai fait
un bisou bisou cousine
c'est ça que je sentais s'est pas dit
bonjour ça pour moi oui ça va déposer ça
va ça va bien j'espère bien oui tu fais
ton film j'ai fait et ça y est c'est
fini tout l'été oui ça sort quand moi tu
vas tu viens ici un bar et là là là je
me mettrai toutes les plages bien ce jeu
mettra toutes les places mal et après tu
as prévu quoi donc le film celle là en
ce moment je suis en train de faire un
film avec bernard lecoq pour la
télévision française 'merci' onale et
puis après je vais peut-être reprendre
les monologues du vagin les prochaines
et puis après je vais peut-être tourné
brad pitt parce que bon tu mens pas je
le connais très bien
ouais je sais donc
là c'est très sympa manège avec lui
c'est toi aussi tu l'as vu les très
sympa bras d'un et pourquoi quand moi je
me suis assise on n'a pas parlé un petit
peu genre tu chantes pas bientôt parce
qu'on savait qu'on avait faire
maintenant séquence c'est quand je me
boulet que moi je ne chante pas voilà et
donc on a prévu pour toi je m'égare
minutes que ton actu lna à part ce
pugilat
je chante dans mon pull sous lequel je
ne suis pas toute nue j'en ai demandé si
la foule et maboul je chanterai le au
china club les 20 janvier 27 janvier et
3 février
j'ai pas le droit de le dire à 6 ans
exception
merci bien
je te dis bon soir à toi aussi et oui
voilà
et voilà et oui tu as perdu tu es et tu
ne sais le mal est fait
à
[Musique]
j'ai passé une bonne idée catherine
parce qu'ils aient un peu plus tôt quand
même là non non mais il était trop loin
tu as bien fait de le voir non c'est un
livre contre la télé réalité donc on lui
montre ce que c'est la télé réalité
voilà tu peux être éliminé d'un moment à
l'autre on peut te demander un quart de
finaliste la main au cul pour lui
demander de quitter le nid est enfermé
dans un château rien rien du tout il est
d'avoir exhibé devant ces réactions seul
novice semaine j'ai trouvé que thierry
était fermé serge telle caméra pour
richard seff j'aimerais que j'aimerais
qu'on lui demande ce qu'ils pensent de
son expulsion
comment ils trouvent l'idée d'avoir été
viré comme ça bêtement subitement des
plateaux très bien richard merci
production agit alors d joseph macé
scaron
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
as tu encore joseph je le crois pas vous
êtes directeur de la rédaction du figaro
magazine et vous avez un tatouage sur le
bras ils le savent au figaro ce verrou
maintenant c'est ça c'est ça le figaro
et le journal la croix ils ont des
piercings cdthed c'est tout le thème du
gouverneur et jugé pas les gens sur leur
apparence c'est tout le thème de l'homme
libéré non mesdames bon prix orwell
sinon c'est bien celle-là ça dépote mon
vélo je viens pas seul vous n'avez
jamais les pieds au figaro en manche
court d'imagination mais sûr que si bien
sûr que si il disait rien là au début ça
surprend
j'ai ouï 1 même moi ça ne choque bah oui
mais sans liberté de blâmer il n'est pas
d'éloge flatteur
absolument non mais là flatteur c'est
chiant pour un tatouage parce que tu
peux pas quand vais-je non mais le là le
truc du tatouage et illustre bien là
quand je les fais d'abord à la première
fois que j'ai fait deux ou trois jours
après je suis allé dans les alpes à ce
que je disais bon allez hop j'ai fait un
tatouage ya longtemps mais au moins je
suis singulier je me différencie des
autres et quand je suis arrivé j'ai faim
dans les halles j'ai vu tout le monde
avait un tatouage une arrivée un peu
l'air con donc je me suis d'abord on se
croise on se croit rebelles à
l'uniformité puis manque de pot bas on
est plus que les fonctionnaires de
l'uniforme
oui ceux qui sont rebelles aujourd'hui
c'est ce compact tatouages maintenant il
faut reconnaître le fait d'être obèse se
situe pas en tout cas avoir un tatouage
comme moi ou non alors qu'angelina jolie
ma nouvelle amie elle elle a un tatouage
sur la nuque à la barre à sur l'avenue
que les mêmes têtes de thénia qui si
elle a un truc avec marquez connais tes
droits
son sac à main sans site se faire
tatouer connais tes droits quand on sait
que c'est que le monde fonctionne aussi
mal j au moment où tu es en train de
lire tu as besoin de connaître alors
joseph macé scaron bonsoir soir le
théâtre et on peut dire je joue le
tatoué on entend des pots donc vous êtes
directeur des rédactions du figaro
magazine vous collaborez à lci rtl
france culture et publié des essais les
politiques rate la tentation
communautaires et des romans dont le
cavalier de minuit voilà l'arbre publié
aujourd'hui chez plon l'homme libéré
alors l'homme libéré dites vous
c'est un homme débarrassé du conformisme
ambiant qui osent penser par lui-même
le paradoxe c'est qu'on est dans une
situation née dans une société où on
entend partout il faut être authentique
faut être soi même
cet endroit c'est ton choix et c'est
assume le et puis à côté on passe son
temps aussi arranger des gens dans des
cases dans des dans les tiroirs et ça de
plus en plus c'est seul paradoxe de ce
livre le paddock de ce livre c'est qu'on
est dans un monde en théorie de plus en
plus complexes et qu'on demande aux
personnes aux individus à vous comme moi
toutes les personnes ici peut-être un
unique voilà donc d'une multiplication
des gourous 12 multiplication de
multiplication des gourous et médecins
diététiciens les sexologues qui en fait
sont prêts à tout coach s'en serait
avant tout pour nous libérer de la
liberté le principe c'est surtout ne
pensez pas on va s'occuper d'eux on va
s'occuper tout sur tout on va s'occuper
de vous dire ou es ce que vous voulez
aller ce que vous devez faire la manière
dont vous devez vous habiller feinte ou
quoi et ça on le voit de plus en plus si
on voit des le paradoxe c'est qu'on
devrait être dans une société de plus en
plus libre et qu' on passe son temps
nous mêmes d'ailleurs on passe son temps
à rechercher ce que j'appelle des niches
identitaire comme si la liberté c'est un
fardeau parce que c'est vrai que la
liberté c'est inconfortable
c'est
c'est difficile quoi assumer oui est ce
que vous dites c'est qu'il ya de plus en
plus de gourou et quand les gourous
s'empare de la religion ils deviennent
vraiment dangereux confère l'islamisme
mais là on peut parler de l'islamisme et
avec ce qui est arrivé aux etats-unis
on voit bien que c'est pas simplement
contre l'islamisme c'est aussi c'est
aussi bien sûr on voit une forme de
fondamentalisme catholiques ou
protestants arriver donc c'est ça c'est
dire qu'aujourd'hui on se dit c'est dit
pardon à une époque il ya plus
d'idéologie on a même proclamé la fin
des idéologies
manque de bol la nature enfin en tout
cas nature intellectuelle horreur du
vide et l'idéologie maintenant est
devenue religieuse mais elle est devenue
religieuse et elle est devenue beaucoup
plus pernicieuse parce qu'elle s'occupe
à la fois du privé est à la fois la vie
publique alors quand il ya eu la chute
du communisme quand tous les cas ses
limites il est arrivé il ya eut dit vous
une bonne période qui est une espèce de
pérestroïka intellectuelle en france
avec les nouveaux philosophes de l'air
d'être assez nostalgique derrière de
cette époque
et là on pouvait penser qu'effectivement
l'homme serait libérée et finalement
depuis il n'a fait que recherchait à
commencer par le fondamentalisme qu'ils
soient chrétiens ou musulmans d'ailleurs
il n'a fait que recherchait à rentrer de
nouveau dans des niches et dans des
cases et c'était pas que reste comme une
espèce de bulle quoi c'est vrai qu'à une
époque où tout est possible c'est un
lieu où les gens pouvaient plus
facilement fin je trouve plus facilement
qu'aujourd'hui débattre sans tout de
suite qu'on s'envoie la vaisselle
idéologique à la tête corps est donc
alors que maintenant ça devient de plus
en plus difficile c'est maintenant c'est
leur vient l'époque on dit d'où tu
parles qui tu es et essayer de te
définir et à partir du moment où on est
arrivé à te choper une fois pour toutes
en te disant tenté d'entrée de gaz
impossible d'en sortir et ça le problème
il ya une sorte de morale collective
qu'on veut imposer c'est à dire que il
ya quand même une période où on faisait
plus confiance à la morale individuelle
c'est à dire bah vous comme moi on
choisissait la carte en 6è voilà je
choisis telle religion ou tel type de
comportement ou rien d'ailleurs rien si
je veux pas de gourou des goûts etc
tandis qu'aujourd'hui de plus en plus on
voit des morale collective vouloir
s'installer et ça y est ça un peu
partout à une époque on les a rejetées
bien sûr que nous avons énormément parce
que rien que moi je l'aimé
à l'intérieur de charlie hebdo aguerris
qui était quand même le centre du monde
ou en rejetaient absolument tout c'était
contraignant en pensez en tout cas
c'était la liberté totale libéré oui oui
alors que on a la sensation que ou 30
ans plus tard tout est revenu au centre
0 et où effectivement la pensée ne doit
être que tel qu on est catalogué quoi
n'est plus quelque chose de d'avant tiff
c'est vrai et de rebelles ça devient un
truc très très fermé et donc je suis
d'accord avec rené gareau c'est pour une
fille du professeur choron croyez-moi ce
temps alors vous effectivement on voit
bien que votre modèle c'est si raymond
aron un conservateur ouvert dites vous
un libéral solitaire alors vous dites il
y avait une très belle phrase sur les
conservateurs
vous dites conservateurs c'est celui qui
cherche à préserver la flamme et non pas
les cendres il ya quelques belles
phrases visite est moderne ce n'est pas
entériné la définition de nous-mêmes que
le monde nous impose
je crois que c'est se construire en
permanence être en permanence et en
permanence au mouvement
c'est reconnaître que pardon de fer sous
cette forme et se reconnaître que
l'homme finalement se définit par la
somme de seat la salle de ce qui fait et
ça toute sa vie jusqu'au bout vous dites
quand on s'occupe pas des idées
ce sont les idéologies qui s'occupe de
vous oui on le voit aujourd'hui
d'où cette idée que vous défendez
finalement de se remettre sans arrêt en
question ne pas ne pas prendre pour
argent comptant les idéologies qu'on
nous impose et elle tous les jours soit
même à la recherche d'une vérité
éphémère mais d'une vérité quand même
quoi ya pas deux il ya pas besoin de
penseurs maîtres penseurs piètre
penseurs tout ce qu'on voudra y a pas
besoin de bourreau je crois que chacun
peut cependant main il ya une phrase que
j'adore le christ n'a pas voulu faire
des chrétiens mais des hommes c'est
tellement si elle n'a heureusement c'est
tellement vrai
[Applaudissements]
c'est bien connu
vous en pensez-quoi en vrai c'est pas
mal non
pdc s'est inspirée par montaigne a bien
sûr des roses et les fans et c'est sûr
j'ai fait un de ses poursuivants
et là aussi je me suis fait la tête de
montagne c'est pour ça avant alors des
fois c'est vrai que vous êtes patron la
direction du figaro magazine quand on
vous écoute comme ça on se demande si
vous êtes vraiment de vraiment de droite
quoi bas - oui moi je pense que je suis
doit leur geste et le test c est si vous
étiez de gauche
jdo alors joseph macé scaron faut-il
dépénaliser la consommation du cannabis
ah ça c'est la grande question que tout
le monde en pas question pour savoir si
vous êtes de droite ou de gauche
question je sais pas je sais pas mais
bon je sais pas bien bon continue
faut-il organiser la délivrance
d'héroïne pour les junk clients en
france
non non est-ce que vous lisiez pif
gadget quand vous étiez petit ah oui à
sa radio gauche ça c'est un truc de
communisme gadget
j'ai jamais mangé les daphnies des
poissons bon d'accord les auteurs du
mexique non plus faut-il interdire le
porno en france non faut-il punir
pénalement les clients des prostituées
non faut-il autoriser les mariages entre
homosexuels deux fois oui et
entreprennent
faut-il autoriser l'adoption des enfants
par les couples homosexuels
je ne sais pas est ce que vous aimez les
chansons de georges brassens
ben oui est-ce que vous avez déjà porté
un t-shirt che guevara ah non est-ce
qu'il faut légaliser l'euthanasie
ouais c'est non c'est difficile ça on
appelle ça me ramène une expérience
personnelle que j'ai dû faire moi même
parce que les infirmières voulais pas le
faire
ouais voilà donc est ce que les
étrangers doivent voter aux élections
locales
non est ce que vous êtes pour la peine
de mort
quand on a tué un enfant ou un policier
non est ce que vous aimez yves duteil
pas trop aidé de bush n'ont peut-être
qu'il adorait
[Rires]
est ce que vous aimez didier barbelivien
c'est qui bon faut-il supprimer le smic
pour relancer l'économie
non l inverse parce que vous serez pas
que les idées d'al hamad là sont
intéressantes
oui vous pensez qu'il faut régulariser
les sans-papiers qui sont en france
depuis longtemps non est-ce qu'il faut
supprimer l' isf
oui est-ce que vous souhaitez que
jacques chirac s'exprime un jour devant
un juge d'instruction
non l'économie de marché est elle la
solution à tous nos maux
non faut-il augmenter le rmi oui les
revers porteriez vous porteriez vous des
chaussettes blanches avec des mocassins
projet déjà feu alors il va voter qu'ils
votent la mort joseph macé scaron
merci d'avoir été avec nous je sais pas
bientôt
[Musique]
à
j'accueille gendarmes ans
[Musique]
jardin non mesdames et messieurs donc
gérard darmon vient pour le blind test
de l'amour le blind test de la 200e de
tout le monde en parle voilà à mon avis
tu vas rien trouvé mais bon c'est bien
ton disque c'est vrai ton film aussi moi
j'étais sérieux et moi c'est moi c'est
pas une vanne parce que je suis sérieux
a aussi gelé seriez 0,6
il se trouve que j'ai rillieux j'ai vu
cet après midi seulement à bon là il est
bien il est très bien j'aime beaucoup
moi un truc ce que tu veux faire à
manger j'ai bien je laime d'armor a
connu ou alors je veux jaune comme ça je
suis blonde parce que c'est depuis
[ __ ] dure
non c'est pas ça c'est que je viens de
finir un film avec eux lanvin et
villeray qui s'appelle les parent 1
saint pal en vain j'étais un peu comme à
l'écran c'est ali ben ouais c'est le
type est et dans le rôle qu'ils jouent
dans le film qui joue le rôle d'une
blanche et un peu susceptible des
cheveux ou et dakar gerra et michel
paulette alors c'est pas moins cher
j'ai essayé j'ai essayé bon chèque émis
consentis
ça va venir lemmy constantine donc et le
fils d'eddie constantine dont il était
le fils de monsieur constantine offs qui
qui étaient russes voient la voiture et
tout ça c'est bien beau mais ça c'est
bien bosser ça c'est la fiche bien
bosser ça c'est du sérieux
hérésie constantine c'est ça si pépé
mais ce robinet nous rend tous sacrés
siegle d'émoustiller ti réglé c'est ça
la vie d
[Musique]
alors on parle et on parlait de votre
père ici la semaine dernière avec eddy
mitchell qui disait que son père lui
faisait lire les livres de piqueurs
chenet et qu'ensuite ils allaient voir
la môme vert-de-gris au cinéma avec avec
eddie constantine sacré personnage eddie
constantine c'est un chanteur acteur qui
avait créé le héros l'ennemi [ __ ] tu
te souviens de sa mort bah oui moi aussi
quand j'étais petit eddie constantine
jeudi la môme vert-de-gris c'était cet
homme est dangereux
les femmes s'en balance ou les films de
bernard borderie c'est dit c'est bernard
qui a qui a commencé la série de ma
micro atx et voilà avec le monde perd de
grille ouais c'est vachement bien avec
la fameuse réplique à dominique wils
j'embrasse vraiment comme une saucisse à
lui parler comme ça est la même voie
ouais ouais et alors après il a fait un
film avec jean luc godard qui s'appelait
alphaville et ça a été terrible parce
qu'au départ ils étaient flattés de
tourner avec godard en fait godard a
complètement détruit le mythe c'est ce
qui a détruit ce qu'est ce qui a rendu
ce qu'il a finalement rendu légende
vivante que l'once de sautes de culte ou
et d'une part puisque après quelques
années plus tard la nouvelle génération
des metteurs en scène allemand ont l'ont
accueilli donc ça d'un côté ça détruit
son toute l'image de la micro chine des
années 50
et ça lui a redonné une troisième vie
puisque vrai avec il a tourné avec des
filles bien frais avec fassbender
il a fini avec europa avec lars von
trier films de godard après il a refait
à neuf zéros
voilà maintenant le problème
effectivement c'est que james bond est
arrivé et et c'est vrai que l'ennemi
[ __ ] face à james bond une autre une
autre époque c'étaient les années
cinquante ans que ray c'était du presque
de série b un mélange de humphrey bogart
sinatra mec pas très beau mais charmant
le charmant avec les filles et un peu
dur avec les mecs
quand sega de whisky et jpp c'est un peu
l'ancêtre de sexe oui c'est vrai
absolument les récents succès ça fait
mal et ça ça va par un soir le samedi le
dimanche des plantes
j'ai été élevé avec chaque élément 93
d'une crise cardiaque à wiesbaden oui
oui vivait avec sa troisième femme voilà
alors il avait la réputation d'être un
grand séducteur et un formidable amant
est ce que c'est vrai les mii moi je
suis un peu mal placé pour le japon
hérité de sécurité de quelque chose mais
c'est la gueule et peut-être de
s'asseoir et à une bonne gueule vraiment
une bonne gueule c'est quand tu tu fais
tu as fait un peu de cinéma
non tu fais des voix mais surtout tu
chantes cela fait pas mal d'albums
on va écouter ce qu'il fait
[Musique]
et
c'est un jeu
[Musique]
je sais pas
sautez pas net
de fait
entrée libre
plus extrait de manouches landes ça
s'appelle paul evans et lemmy
constantine alors c'est vrai que en fait
vos deux parents sont d'origine slave
puisque le père c'est constantinople ce
qui en fait sans son vrai nom c'est
quelqu'un qui venait de russie et votre
mère c et link à mussy l'eau va vite
hélène musil c'est beaucoup plus simple
ce qui était une ballerine chez check
exceptions en fait cette musique c'est
quelque chose qui est assez atavique
chez vous je dirais oui oui le gall 2
via le principe du voyage chez les
manouches mangel j'ai intitulé l'album
manouche lente parce que c'est un reflet
de justement de ces différentes musiques
oh
au hasard des voyages des rencontres on
a envie de jouer delà de la bossa nova
du boléro du ternaire de la valse
musette
il ya tout ça dans l'album et je suis
ravi dessus du souk très content du
résultat
je suis d'ailleurs en train d'en
préparer un autre très bien je suis très
heureux de vous avoir connu les mêmes
merci beaucoup lemmy constantine merci
beaucoup
m
google
[Applaudissements]
blige thèse de la mort blinkx de la mort
on la 200e émission j'accueille en
moyenne
et parce qu'un seul
[Applaudissements]
baba en tout cas terry je viens de
recompter les émissions tu t'es trompé
c'est la 199e ce soir répond alors on va
des commandes et nos amis et aux
platines j'appelle match un supporter
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
yahoo
il
oui c'est la thèse de la mort c'est le
blind th de la 200 combattants fille
annie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ouais
[Musique]
des cadeaux pour leurs employés
le rendre déconner tout
ayoub
[Applaudissements]
la première semaine
les bernois
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
samassa
ayez un pays qui fait rêver ou pas qui
c'est rêver oui le brésil
oui il ya la table ainsi ou sans col
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui tu sais ce qui va du soulier non il
m'a dit pitaya de la meuf
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je voulais présenter dans le val on
l'appelle didier lasaygues y en a 3 les
trois jeunes filles arrivent de
carcassonne elle était avec laurent
boyer ya pas très longtemps c'est pour
ça que c'était pour lui faire plaisir et
puis la dernière arrive de sao paulo ah
oui et les c'est le sud aussi
voilà attention donc vous connaissiez le
principe de finesse une élève récent
accord c'est par équipes a gelé c'est le
principe d'avancés l'équipe d'elena
contre l'équipe de michel bernier est ce
que tu es prêt qui est prêt toi bref
c'est mon métier
allez vas-y première chanson qui a
trouvé hier
[Applaudissements]
je crois que ça fait un point pour
l'équipe de michel bernier par normand
cela s'est rarement
jérôme hamon mais cette envie c'est en
même temps que pascal semaine n'a pas
besoin de ripper c'est vous qui avez
gagné ça ça fait 1 pour cette équipe là
voilà maintenant single c'est pour ça
qu'on a partagé des gc ca ce sont les
tubes de toujours pas guérir à temps la
règle essentielle baisse d'affilée
vous avez le droit de jouer mais avec
les nouveaux morceaux les gars hectares
on continue pas de français donc pas non
c'est maintenant s'ils jouent pas un
ouais super
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
roselyne garde
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tout le monde a peur
qui c est ce que quelqu'un c'est moi je
sais toi tu sais oui c'est normal
pourtant c'est pas normal que laurent ne
sache pas c'est une femme
oui c'est une femme walo walo voix
donc le point bas la méline le point bas
là puisque c'est quelqu'un de ce côté là
qui a trouvé vraiment
[Musique]
donc ça peut poids pour l'équipe de
michel bernier zéro point son équipe
helena noguerra voilà on continue
philippe tomasetti classe incroyable
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
5wasquehal chaîne
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non bravo sur le thème paie pas bravo
philippe je suis prêt
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c
gérard darmon
ja
bravo vraiment voilà gérard il m'a tuer
parce que c'est un truc qu'on allait le
dire tu partirais de la gauche c'est
tout le jeu est là là gérard maman ah
oui non c'est bien qu'il sache ça
franchement on continue philippe c'est
black eyed peas fouet
[Applaudissements]
voilà black eyed peas bien sûr parler
quand on vous dit que ce sont les
chansons de l'émission on continue
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
navi pillay bravo non tu sembles moi
mais c'est sauvé le seul bénéficiaire un
gros con l'attitude scandaleuse
oh non ça fait un bon l'équipe d'elena 5
pour le type de michèle bernier
bravo nagui en tous les cas tu sauve
l'honneur trois continents guy we were
continuent à s'abattre
la vie
[Applaudissements]
hélas
[Musique]
non
si je peux me permettre c'est kid creole
and the way
[Applaudissements]
je vends défendre notre ami qui lui joue
avec jean vigneau chaque semaine est
passée j'avais ce point que les arts
attention film
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non laurent belvis les pages la fed ce
soir
permettez moi des gens chollon des
frères jacques alors c'est sur pièce
claire et vous allez voir comment ça va
faire tourner tu gagnes tu toi et te
mets 10 eric charden meneghel battu
cannes michel
oui mais c'est scandaleux et la semaine
dernière il a reconnu les soeurs etienne
pascal sellem c'est pour te dire que il
avait couché avec une des deux d'accord
c'est la vie privée
non
oh
[Applaudissements]
m
et
oh
à
[Applaudissements]
pascale ferran non
mais attention tu viens et saint clar tu
ne bouges pas tu ne dis rien toi même si
l'impôt que derrière c'est la victoire
habitat de baby baby bravo
[Applaudissements]
d'une fois
c'est une femme
[Applaudissements]
donc ça veut dire trois points pour
l'équipe de l'ena ci sous l'égide de
michèle bernier c'était évidemment
bellini excuse moi mais je fais jouer
les femmes en premier - partenaires bah
ouais excuse moi partenaire c'était bien
élevé eddy mitchell on continue
[Musique]
ouais ouais
non à rémy rien jouer parce qu'un seul
gloria estefan bravo pascal célèbre
trois mâts jansson chine
c'est plutôt miami sa machine julien et
stéphane et maya me sens me she may b
comme tu n'as pas dit non plus mais non
plus n'ont pas vu comme une insulte au
géant garçons
[Musique]
et les peuples us for life un bravo j'ai
rarement un quad a déchiré le c'est vrai
que cette voie on se demande toujours
s'attacher les trois verres de gasoil
sais pas ce que je voulais dire mal est
fait philippe encore dit georges daher
[Musique]
il
jamais
tariq ramadan non bon soir s'est refait
natif brevets
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
orix albert
là
m
ces tournesols sous un beau soleil les
fleurs
une battle avec core team est bon qu'il
faut refaire andré dussollier plus
pêchus refaire maintenant julie baup
orties
non
ouais
[Applaudissements]
voilà donc c'est david guetta évidemment
s'avère plus de fruits puisque 2011
voilà alors donc au rendez vous ouais
alors l'équipe d'helena noguerra 5
l'équipe de michel bernier 8 bravo
messieurs
[Applaudissements]
continuez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ouais
bon et là cela c'est très très très
compliqué c'est le dernier du par
équipes c'est très très difficile et
c'est quoi le noir non non aussi je vous
donne un indice chez vous un indice chez
vous un indice chez vous à lundi ce
qu'est ce qu'il a fait lui ont le plein
air
[Musique]
non alors dans le marbre en vo ça ça
fait un point à 6,6 ici ça fait 6 à 20
voire indien vers le nord mais pas s'il
l'a fait il a fait que deux chansons
pour herbert léonard et julien lepers
son ensemble tirs et il a fait que deux
chansons pour herbert léonard c'était
facile en même temps à temps
certes je te donnerai pas le point toi
[Musique]
jean pierre vial égalisation égalisation
alors fait encore nuit c'est alors c'est
juste c'est injuste qui presque une
catherine la vie est injuste oui c'est
vrai regardez un titre alain titres
français pour voilà pour bernie et
d'armand d'accord je trouvais attention
non on fait un titre français attention
québécois maintenant je veux
l'interprète
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est jeannette à ma fille
[Applaudissements]
ouais
je vous demande de rien était bon alors
maintenant on arrive à c'est le dernier
du par ailleurs c'est très compliqué oui
balladur c'est une équipe à qui je vous
donne un indice chez vous d'accord
featuring charles est basse et philippe
wahl
[Applaudissements]
bye
[Musique]
ça j'adore les gens quand tu leur dis
featuring chiant les bassidjis
propellerhead ouais ça génial là tu m'as
scotch et je t'adore franc je t'aime
c'est quand même elena qui gagne alors
que vous avez menées
brando elena bravo j'ai encore beaucoup
marqué et branchements et je pense je
pense surtout qu'on peut rien faire
quand on à l'arbitré contre nous c'est
l'arbitré à la maison ça c'est cet après
midi j'ai dit à laurence ricoche je
pense pas que gérard trouve grand chose
oui et tu as trouvé quatre titres à bien
durs et c'était dur et ça tourne en rond
avant maintenant on arrive au chacun
pour sa gueule
donc il n'y a plus d'amis parce que la
vie est injuste
maintenant il n'y a plus d'amis
effectivement c'est le libéralisme
absolu l'ultralibéralisme chacun pour sa
gueule
seuls les plus forts survivront ouais
ben asie
selon lui si j'ai peur de pas entendre
vraiment qui c'est laurent boyer stand
funk mars et un triplet nord chaque
attaque
alice dona non cerrone qui fait les
harkis c'est bien bien bien c'est que
j'ai entendu un truc là non il a trouvé
là bas il ya trouvé là il a trouvé à
temps s'il a trouvé ses fins il a trouvé
la trouvez s'il a trouvé une très fort
il a sauvé réduire la faiblesse de la
mort tu ne dis rien tu ne dis rien vient
toi donc comme ses deux garçons
je vais les prendre non je vais d'être
gelée pendant l'oreille je vais prendre
à l'oreille circuit de la bonne réponse
tu me dit doucement alors être doucement
à l'oreille en armement oui et toi non
si toi gagné bravo
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
émargeant donc celui ou celle qui va
trouver la réponse sera la superstar du
monde entier chez top of the world
c'est vrai dussollier andré tu trouvais
ça tu trouves ça c'est vrai je sens
philippe ceci près
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
périple je crois que guy l'a dit avant
moi gendarmes on le dirait franchement
ce soir tu as tu vraiment c'est très
bien merci mais c'est pas toi qui a dit
le premier bravo c'est pascal sellem
[Applaudissements]
voilà
oui
mais
j'étais tout le monde enfin orlando
merci orlando matt damon brad pitt
jeunes shiden égérie wenbo prochaine
fois que tu chéris soderbergh avec andy
garcia je viens anvers voilà isabelle
huppert
les soeurs fâchées d'alexandra leclère
avec catherine coole le 22 décembre
oliver stone angelina jolie colline par
al dans alexander de l'hiver stone avec
val kilmer anthony hopkins
sortie le 5 janvier j'en bave dit merci
laurent gibio dre tu vas rire mais je te
quitte depuis les paroles avec sagamore
stévenin
sortie le 5 janvier richard sette son
livre s'appelle la décadence et c'est
publié chez flammarion événements
l'album s'appelle la note bleue et chez
blue note voilà un album évidemment le
pouls de nougaro andré dussollier
monstres sacrés sacrément les athlètes
dans leur tête en alternance au théâtre
de la gaîté montparnasse jusqu'au 2
janvier
joseph macé scaron l'homme libéré chez
plon lemmy constantine
l'album s'appelle manouche langues le 25
janvier à dijon
17h11 au poly bergère de paris voilà le
black death merci philippe corti soirée
du 31 décembre 2004 au dock des suds à
marseille avec david guetta bob sinclar
et martin solveig voilà merci voilà
helena noguerra l'album s'appelle ni
dans la nature on concert le jeudi 20 et
27 janvier
je crois février au china club de paris
voilà c'est fini je vous le livre mukuna
sur dieudonné parce que j'ai dit qu'il
était interdit en france en fait ce
livre n'est pas interdit en france
il est autorisé en france mais c'est pas
pour ça qu'il faut le dire voilà c'était
un tournant par pascal sellem dvd le
foot en délire le bêtisier équipe lortie
la musique du générique justice voilà
plus l'opération brigade au poireau le
papier cadeau acheté trois vaccins pour
l'unicef voilà merci beaucoup et bien on
se retrouve le 8 janvier pour la
prochaine lui jambières
oui janvier voilà merci merci de votre
fidélité
encore 200
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
we are a il ya fait aux lèvres il argué
mme en clamant
[Musique]
non
que
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ben
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pékin
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu